Xfinity freaking taking my internet out
on Monday
on a
so this is what we've gotten so far from
the MOBA
interesting we can see this like big
Improvement in Elo
uh I don't know if that's a new message
from Peter or not or if it just buffered
that but uh that's learning breakout
from
images there's no reason I don't
personally think there's any reason to
do it from images versus State it's just
that's what's
available original Atari
I don't know if the metrics are accurate
if everybody just refound the stream
since it went back up but yeah hopefully
so welcome
these These are actually very short
training runs as
well the best one only
takes yeah that's
nothing less than 15
minutes
so if the thing goes down again I'll
probably just go do something else for a
couple hours but as long as the stream
holds up out um I think what we should
do is we should just go try to train uh
really good models baselines for
breakout really good model for uh the
Moa based off of these new parameters
and then we will probably let the
breakout sweep finish um and we will go
start looking at like what the policy
actually does in the Moa and if it's any
good so let's just start on that
and I am tired today I tried I tried
running again running and lifting for
the first time since my 50k and my body
is just not recovered at all it was
rough hopefully that uh I get a little
bit more energy back in the next few
days I mean I was also just working on
this stuff like all weekend as
well so that probably didn't
help but we're going to see if we can
make some good progress today at the
very
least we also did have the uh the snake
release demo so that was
fun really just want to like sit down
and like code some C but there's nothing
really for me to do there at the
moment uh okay let's go to the breakout
sweep
parito what's the long form video you're
working on about it's uh it's like all
the stuff it's like an overview of all
the different layers of RL and how
puffer lib is trying to fix everything
it looks like it's going to shape up to
be 20 25 minute video something like
that I know videos are a lot of
work and I put a little poll on Twitter
like to see if people actually want
these anyways and it does seem like
people do um so we'll see you know if if
this one does very well I'll make more
but uh for the amount of time that they
have that they take right like these
videos actually have to get a lot of
eyes on puffer for them to be worth
making so we'll
right this one's like so much faster for
almost the same
stable wonder if we could earn anything
by doing the tournament setup from alpha
star or at
least keep the champion then learn from
scratch but one of the opponents can be
the previous
Champion might have been some fancy no
idea if it
worked keep the
champion
oh uh you can't really do that because
you won't learn anything it's like if a
new model is going up against like the
previous Champion I mean that's like
trying to learn Dota or like trying to
learn a game going up against Grand
Masters you just get
stomped does this look
good I don't like this the value loss
has exploded on
one also exploded very very weird these
things just find the weirdest
darn weird you're just darn
Solutions but you know this one I this
one at least looks
stable so I think we'll keep this
one um
yeah it's pretty
the idea was I'm familiar with the alpha
star thing there was a specific reason
for that um DOTA does it too they had a
well slightly different they had a
historical selfplay
um it's not it's not a naive uh it's not
a naive agent though they're all being
trained at the same time we do have
something like that for evaluation time
like if you SE in this plot we have ELO
over time um but this is only being done
at evaluation mainly because it keeps
the infrastructure simpler so we could
potentially experiment with something
like that but it will substantially
complicate the code cuz it is it's a
fair bit harder to efficiently run
multiple policies at the same
time I'm hoping that we have some cool
models from this we'll see
I'm also so incredibly tempted to Port
this whole thing to see so that like
people can play it online but I know
that's just not a good use of
our let me get our hyper
[Music]
parameters
and
Ranch by the way folks if you're
interested um the snake environment
including the web version is now in
puffer so you can go play this online
and you can actually go get the code for
this now runs 100% client side very
happy with how this turned
out funny thing is I could do the exact
same thing with anything in
puffer when you say C is it pure C or
scyon no it is pure C I wouldn't say
pure C if it were cython I've said that
when I say I have syon I say it runs in
pure C because it does but this one is
actually written in pure C which is how
it's compiled for web I can't compile
scon for web or I would just do that but
frankly the C is not really any worse
the C is actually very
cozy that said if you're contributing
environments to perer scon is fine and
scon will be just as
fast it is a very nice Gateway though to
lower level programming very nice
Gateway all right let's see oops not MOA
uh
breakout see is
cozy yeah you know I really I never got
into see because in undergrad I had the
worst damn lecturer ever for my systems
classes the same one for both of the
core systems classes and I hated it it
was just the worst thing
but now now that I'm actually going back
see is really nice see it's kind of like
the solution to a lot of things oh you
want stuff to be online but you don't
want to deal with JavaScript Madness you
can just write it and
see and that's somehow more sayane than
having to write
JavaScript and also it runs locally too
which is very nice you can have a
desktop app and a browser app at the
same time the same exact code very
nice
Lama GMA I like scyon I like scon too
you know the one thing I have not found
in see yet um is something like scyon
memory views memory views are just so
good like just having good support for
multi-dimensional arrays is so important
and um I haven't found a good
replacement for
that I think if I had that then I like I
would just write stuff in C by default
because it would literally be the same
thing with less hassle um I'd still use
syon for the bindings though anyway so
like
yeah the compile times are nice
though I still like scon sion's really
like a killer killer app of
python you can just write scon you can
totally just write
syon only it was a triple header
there the only there are a couple bad
things with scon they're like a few
times you get really Jank error messages
um the debug tools that are built in are
not amazing and the compile times are
God awful because it has to First
translate to a massive C file those are
kind of the things that I don't like
with
scon everything else is very very
nice you can pretty much build whatever
the heck you could build in like you can
build it in syon you can build it in C
it'll be the same um it'll be like
you'll have different inconveniences
either way and there's no performance
reason one or the other so like for
people contributing Sims to puffer scon
is
AOK and if something's real really
really cool maybe I'll help Port it to
see so we can run like a cool web demo
but it's not needed at
all I mean it's really just showing off
more than
anything kind of funny how all these
different environments always have frame
skip 4 I'm almost positive I'm sweeping
this Piper parameter and it just always
discovers Fram skip 4 is the best which
is actually fun because the default is
five in um the makato stuff I think and
that's actually wrong the defaults of
five look substantially
worse bet you if this whole UI were not
written in JavaScript it would be uh
wouldn't be lagging right
now time steps we'll do 25 million time
stamps batch size all these parameters
looks
good do I want to run this on my local
as a
benchmark it's kind of obnoxious
right I don't have a box to run this on
right yet
it's okay we'll just update the configs
for now we'll probably train the mobile
one locally because that one's
fast but we have that now and here we
have the
good we'll go for this
one oh that train so fast what
huh we get like all sorts of wonky
looking curves it's really funny like I
would not expect this to be a good model
but according to the auto sweep it's a
good
model hi there
welcome oh yeah I think most folks saw
this already but we uh we passed 800
Stars last week which is nuts at 808 now
if you haven't started the project
already go ahead and do that helps me
out a ton and uh yeah we got lots more
stuff coming
here I like just watching this demo it's
it's a lot of
fun you know maybe I'll just like can I
like hold
on I totally can right can I just like
put this up at the top of my screen
yeah we'll do
that there now I can enjoy it and you
can
too it barely takes any CPU it's like
tiny little one core
simulation
okay
MOA this the right one yeah let's go
grab these hypers
whoops let's see how much it changed the
hyper parameter so this is like
supposedly this is dramatically better
than before uh the reward death reward
is very
similar okay the distance reward is
massive so I'm actually kind of
concerned here that this thing is just
like a running straight down mid um yeah
we'll see about that that's a little
sketchy Tower and then reward
XP it's funny these hyper prams do not
look great but according to this run
this has the highest win
size same as before
actually BPT Horizon of two yeah
I'm I think that this is most likely it
found like an exploit in the game or
very low
entropy and batch sence
4 H the lamb the uh
J lambda's
reasonable gamma is at least more
reasonable than before though it's still
quite low I
think learning rate
O2 pretty
aggressive reasonable Max grade grad
actually I'm happy to see this this
should be way more stable than before
mini batch of
32k kind of weird how low that is that's
like it's very low for the uh the batch
size total time steps we'll just do 250
mil that'll be pretty
that's it's like not training the value
function man it's just not training the
value function that's
bizarre maybe I should just not include
these in the
sweep because like it it makes it find
weird degenerate Solutions I don't know
we'll consider that for
sure but for now that's uh that's all
the parameters that's those are all the
params um
so we'll do a track
run this one should be relatively quick
even on my
local four update EPO is not going to be
crazy fast though we'll see
30 was
that 350k steps per second on the big
puffer
goes no there's no way it's that slow
right 91 we're not running that if it's
that slow
update you know we're not waiting 40
minutes for this we're running this on
the big puffer box
oops
uhoh
cannot is tail scale
down now this is the Box running the
breakout sweep so we're going to leave
this one
and yeah we can kill this this is right
in between experiments which is
perfect it's already done over 500 here
so we're happy with
okay and did we get the new config you
yes we
did
mobile train V
multiprocessing
this is It's supposed to run 350k yeah
there you go 300 some odd and it'll
change over
time that's much better 11 minutes to
wait for
this we'll put this on the other monitor
in the meantime and we'll see oops
also running
breakout mine is running 300K steps per
second on
CPU dang you're doing
like are you doing like paddle state or
brick state are you actually doing like
you know like it fills in like maybe
like a grid observation but it's like
one cell is a brick like I I have to
look at how you're doing it but yeah
300K for a breakout it like you should
basically be able to Auto solve that M
because that's 10 times faster than um
the actual breakout environment runs
even with all of puffer's optimizations
on a high-end
box but also you should be able to get a
million we'll get you a million I'll
help you optimize that once you have
something nice and
stable I'm very interested in that I'm
very happy to see people contributing to
Puffer
have I missed any of your questions on
the Discord like the Pokemon guys just
Spam the hell out of the dev channel the
other day and I just went and ask forw
it and I kept like working on
stuff I got like a good probably 25
hours of work done just this
weekend I'm also hoping that this snake
en actually get some attention on on X I
was hoping that this would do a little
better by now I guess it's still just
been a few
cool
also this guy is just cracked he makes
the best stuff like RB is amazing like
you really owe it to yourself if you
like programming at all to use Raab
stuff it's just
awesome this guy is
awesome I love his
work
whoops oh I didn't realize you can't
zoom
multiple that's
okay all right let me think what we're
going to do in the meantime
so it's really the thing I want to get
done today is I want to understand
hopefully this policy is good enough um
that I'm going to be able to use this to
like understand the MOBA better and what
needs to be
balanced and we're probably going to add
some changes here as well um to enable
it to learn more interesting stuff
it's interesting because
like I think it's a 200 ELO difference
is a 75% win rate let me
look yeah so 7 let's say 75 for every
200 points so if this thing is let's say
like versus these early runs let's say
like the sweep gave us 400 points versus
some of the earlier runs right that
should be
a 15 out of 16 win rate versus some of
these early models and versus like the
really just randomly trained ones down
here uh it's like a one it's a 63 and 64
win rate versus these is how this should
read Because yeah that's that's the way
ELO works now whether that actually
happened or something weird went on
we'll see about that um but this is very
promising I mean this is a nice plot
right maybe I shouldn't have full
screened
it a 500 experiments right there worth
of
data is that actually our first trillion
let me
think
because these are run running at least
100 million steps each
right so 100
Mil well 50
bill I think it's no it's is it 50
billion steps it depends how long these
actually run for on
average I think it's a it's should be
well over 100 billion though
six minutes left on the run
and you can't the thing is you can't
really tell if it's doing
well because it's all like relative
scoring kind of just want to wait for
this thing um I guess I can talk about
some other plans cuz man I'm just like
tired today I don't know I tried I tried
to like go
run again in the morning it just didn't
work
um so I I guess the main things at the
moment are like this big simulation
update the hyper parameter sweeps
baselines for a few other environments
mostly Atari and the video
um I think a lot should open up after
that but
really I need these simulation projects
to not drag on for so long is the main
thing um like the Moa like the dev went
really fast for like a week maybe two
weeks we got the whole thing implemented
and now we're just stuck like doing
fiddly little experiments and that's the
main failure mode of RL is like getting
stuck for too long doing fiddly little
experiments so I'm hoping that what's
going to happen with these projects is
that they help automate that process
because like right here this carbs this
would be like a month of work before
um at least now if there's something
broken with the EnV like this will
conclusively tell me okay we found the
best possible policy out there for the
environment this is what it is if it's
bad well then that means that something
is
broken
right like broken with the environment
not anything
nice I definitely learning
something I guess I can look at in the
meantime I can also look at
um here I'll talk about how I plan on
balancing this so I did something kind
of cool
I do you see these usage stats here so
these are all the abilities in the game
and uh I we record the average number of
times that they're being used by the
agents so something is being used a lot
it's probably good good and if something
is not being used is probably bad so you
can see that relatively like these
classes are not remotely balanced at the
moment and we probably need
to double check that the abilities that
aren't being used are working in the
first place um and then also
like substantially buff or rework the
ones that are not being
used I know the Assassin e ability
is well this one is a channel so maybe
it's a little misle cuz like it's
recording your usage every time like
every frame you hold it down this is a
move speed buff it's a good ability I
don't think it's broken
though so maybe we should like do like
Mana spent or something instead of
number of times used I don't know what
to think about
that but I can
see you can kind of see that like they
favor us like the tank says it has a
good
Q I guess we'll start looking at these
right after this thing finishes training
because it's only it'll be done in like
three minutes but
um
man it's actually a very nice way of
Auto balancing stuff is if we just see
what they're using we basically like
we've got stats on the level of what a
game company would have right this is
like having like huge numbers of player
stats on what players are using and what
they're not for the purpose of
balancing and like you you kind of just
assume that the players are intelligent
enough to figure out how to use
something if it's good and if they're
not and if they're not using it it's
bad so tank
qw actually tank has two good skills it
uses q and W A lot
support has a good q and W it looks
like doesn't use
e at
all burst
has an okay q and W and not a good e it
looks like just a weat class overall
maybe we didn't do the dam we didn't do
like hero scaling stuff yet
either I don't think
it's a lot of potential rounds of
balancing actually isn't
it I wonder if we could come up with a
way to Auto balance this
right or if it would be too many hyper
parameters like technically could we
just throw like the Mana cost and damage
values of every single ability um into
the hyperparameter sweep and then
difficult that is one of the things RL
can do ultimately though is completely
like autobalance
stuff cuz like when you actually have
real players right you have to wait for
them to give you new data about playing
the game and how what they're doing and
it takes a few weeks for them to figure
out new metas and stuff but all agents
can just do that instantly if the en is
fast
enough the carry
has looks like Carrie only has one good
skill maybe one okay skill they like
their
W okay this is about to be finished
anyways but yeah it's it looks like we
actually did better than I would expect
with the skills in the sense that like
there are a lot of different skills that
are being used so they're at least okay
um and just some of them need to be
buffed up a
bit we'll also see if this like what the
agents are doing makes any sense
whatsoever I I think that they're most
likely just like running it down mid
we'll
see could you suggest a few good methods
to design and validate a reward function
yes so you want to have a metric that's
not based on the reward function first
of all like uh win rate like if they
winning the game or like how far into
the game they're getting something like
that right and then what you do is you
just come up with like maybe five
different components of things that you
think could be important uh like when in
this case for example right like you can
see I there's a reward for getting XP
there's a reward for taking Towers there
is a reward based on your distance from
the enemy ancient there's a reward for
dying and then I don't bother tuning
these at all I let carbs tune the
weights of these for me right so
basically I don't spend any of my time
guessing reward weightings I just say
these are five things that are probably
you know somewhat important overall and
I just give it to
carbs this only works if you have a fast
environment but I would generally
suggest doing work on Fast environments
whenever possible because it's the same
as doing work on slow environments
except that you don't waste like months
of your life you know just waiting on
experiments right here you can see that
this
is the automatically uh this is the
automatic uh evaluation
here what are your plans now that your p
PhD is done these are my plans right
here I'm building puffer
AI it's a company dedicated to
reinforcement learning and it is going
to make a lot of stuff much
easier you can already like in just in
the past 3 months alone we now have the
ability to automatically tune uh several
environments at like 10 times the speed
that they used to run just fully
automatically with very simple code we
have super super fast simulated and
environments for use and research we've
got broadly compatible uh infrastructure
that works with tons of different
simulators I mean we have lots of lots
of good stuff it's moving very fast
here I'm pretty happy with that
overall
[Music]
um I'm hoping it at least saved this run
here to want be if not I'll be able to
grab the file off of my
local let's see
so
projects not carbs it should just be in
puffer okay here's our mobile
run we can see that this Yep this looks
like what it was
before reward yeah look at that the
reward goes up and then it's kind of
cyclical as I think over games or
whatever
do we have the policy here no we don't
have the policy
here I saw a discussion you had on
Twitter about if the environment or the
bottleneck or the algorithms are can you
elaborate on this a bit Yeah so
basically like there's a group of people
that think that RL needs to be really
really sample efficient and the way to
make progress is to do work on that I'm
pretty much betting everything on those
people being wrong so these are like
many of these are capable people who've
done good work but I'm making a pretty
heavy bet on just like there's no way
forward for RL if you focus on uh M's
that are just not fast because your
experiments take too long for you to run
enough of them to get any meaningful
results so I'm essentially what I'm my
plan and this is part of the video uh
that I'm working on but the plan is to
just like replace all the environments
with ultra fast versions make puffer lib
this stupidly simple and high
performance library for just doing
everything instantly and then what
that'll allow us to do is instead of
doing bad science where we're
essentially guessing at what methods
actually make a difference because we
don't have enough experiments to prove
anything uh we will automatically have
conclusive and exhaustive proof for
everything that we do and at that point
we almost don't need to try to make
progress progress will just become
inevitable because of how easy it is to
EV valuate method a versus method B so
that's kind of the way that I'm going
with puffer at the
moment Daman here says killer work
planning on using puffer when I start my
research again this semester especially
since I might not have access to a great
GPU this time around yeah puffer has
some nice fast environments I generally
do suggest having at least some form of
local GPU even if it's just like a
commercial desktop I mean we don't have
crazy fancy stuff at puffer either hold
on where is it this page is Tiny cuz I
have this demo up here but this is one
of the environments you could use uh
where is
it okay here
this this photo yeah this is our cluster
we just use commercial desktops with one
GPU and they're plenty fast with our new
environments you're not even going to
need this much
compute GTX 1080 is H that's a bit rough
but technically like with our snake en
and like with some of the puffer Ms you
can still train at like 10 to 20 times
or more faster than like all the
existing M's like you can run snake at
apparently hundreds of thousands of
steps per second on a CPU so that's
nice I thought about trying to create a
GPU accelerated environment didn't find
a ton of resources it basically done by
using torch for the internal state with
a Cuda back end you can do that you can
also use Jacks these exist uh I
recommend against doing this GPU
accelerated environments have been this
huge thing lately and I think it's a
complete offramp for the vast majority
of work in RL with a few notable
exceptions the reason is that uh gpus
are not just faster CPUs right they're
like really dumb but highly parallel and
that is not what games are and that's
not what Sims are like you need to be
able to do conditional branching logic
and to do that on a GPU you need to get
really tricky about the way you write
stuff and it makes incredibly difficult
to implement complex
Sims if I can Implement a MOA and have
it run at over a million steps per
second per CPU core and then just solve
the vectorization problem with puffer
that's going to be the way to go and at
this point I'm confident that I can
write basically whatever I want like any
sorts of interesting Sims I can make
them run like 10 100 even a thousand
times faster than the rest of the field
is doing right
now in which cases does it make to use
sense to use a GPU accelerated EnV um
certain types of physics simulators that
need High Fidelity physics um certain
types of like uh artificial life type
experiments where you just have like
these massive massive environments that
have tons of very similar like
operations that can basically you can
implement the environment Dynamics as a
convolution uh there are a few things
like that I'd say for the most part
though it's not the way forward like at
all
so here's I will give you the um this is
actually uh I consider this to be the
exception that proves the
rule here's the exception that proves
the
rule do you plan on adding robotics M to
puffer already being done already have
Chung doing uh robotics stuff with this
and a couple other people that have been
trying stuff as well
we'll do some more in the
future so here's the exception that
proves the rule
right
um 3,000
lines of actually very very well written
code it's all Jack so it's like this
crazy functional stuff where you can see
like you're using the same RNG cuz
advents are mutually exclusive coal
amount
so you have all these different random
vectors and then you have like all these
splits on different arrays it's like an
entire game implemented as essentially
array operations and this is an
incredibly good project I love this work
and this runs like I don't know at least
a thousand times faster than the
original
does the thing is if you're really smart
then sure go do this I'm not not smart
enough to do this and I hate solving
tricky problems that involve me having
to write a game using array operations
so I could make this thing run the same
speed at least vectorized on CPU with
much simpler code in like C or scon
that's the way that I would be doing
stuff going forward that said there's no
incentive to do it for this particular
project because this already exists this
is an amazing project um the guy that
did this is awesome um but yeah I think
that like if you're talented enough to
do this and you really like solving
tricky array problems then go ahead but
there are much easier
ways another exception would be
bra yeah I said physics I said High
Fidelity physics Sims
right that was one of the examples I
gave and by the way I've heard from
reputable robotics people that's not
even all robotics like there's stuff
like contact Sims and stuff that are
actually really hard to run on GPU and
fast CPU plus good VEC is actually
potentially
better also your GPU is supposed to be
used for training so like wasting time
that you're supposed to be training on
simulating the en is not always good
unless it's like a trivial
fraction any machine that has gpus
already at least has some CPU scores on
it already
right let's go grab this uh let's go
grabb this thing
MOBA uh supposed to be PT notp but
whatever
it's it's
slash home
day and it's tuned Moa
mode
[Music]
okay okay so they do kind of just rush
each other right
oh that's actually really funny they
found
um I guess that's why Dyer does Dyer
have the bigger win rate
here let's
here I bet you dire has the bigger win
rate because they glitch through the
wall
yeah so ders actually wins a bit more
often because they found a way to glitch
through the wall that's
let's um do we want to load this in
human
go there's like some render glitch hold
on
we might have to fix the render glitch
before we get to play with this too
much that's actually might maybe a bad
sign we'll uh we'll check that
though I think for
now actually I think what we're we're
going to
draw okay so we'll see what the heck
happened here and we also get to
see maybe some
gameplay okay come on let's go
interesting wait what where did my team
go they just rushed right by each other
another okay so I'm doing some work
though they do kind of just murk
you
um I forg forget what my skills do
honestly I'm just clicking
buttons I think I'm going to die here
yeah oh the slow persists that's
funny wait it's teleporting forward
that's
interesting dude I need like better
graphics maybe that's what we should do
today maybe that would be fun let's just
like make this thing actually understand
what the hell's going
on I don't know how we're going to do
animations and stuff though that's kind
of hard ah getting
mobbed they've outleveled me so I assume
that they're doing something correct if
they've outleveled
me yeah this guy's level six what the
hell though I guess I think I'm
technically playing support at the
moment as you can tell by the uh you
know the graphic that is not in any way
different whatsoever from the uh the
default is this game of Life by
Conway this is puffer Mobile by Joseph
Suarez which is basically DOTA ripoff
but with puffer fish that run super
fast okay I do remember that I have
a uh I have an AOE heal that I should be
using right I think I'm also not
supposed to be up here because I'm the
support or
whatever there's something wrong with
the neutrals are there like no neutral
spawning H is the perer MOBA image
available for download yep all my
stuff's open source friend it is all on
the puffer AI GitHub with puffer lib
star the repo on your way in if you
please it helps me out a
ton are we winning because of me playing
like this defensive game I don't think
so CU we have a level 11 somehow I think
some like there's just a class that has
a really overpowered skill or something
and everything's going to depend on
that we should probably do like Levels
by class or something
what programming software is this uh the
simulator for this is written in
scon the reinforcement learning side is
in Python plus pytorch and the renderer
here is in
[Music]
rayb this is kind of fun I'm not going
to lie I don't even know what's going on
but it is kind of fun just clicking
buttons and like thinking I might be
doing
something do I have to go I think I have
to help my team go like close the game
though don't
I yeah let's go puffers oh maybe not we
play some
defense I think I got hit with a slow
that's I just got slowed
if I have a slow though it should show
there should be a cool down down
here did something I meant a picture of
the puffer fish oh is
the uh technically I think yeah you can
get it off of the
website there's also the uh the asset
sheet the Sprite sheet for this is
available now m it is technically also
the company logo so don't do crazy
things with it please but uh you know
you're allowed to meme
it just don't make any
sushi this is actually kind of sweet not
going to
lie like you end up being a pretty good
tank oh you know what's actually going
to be fun we should just go check
whether the RL model agrees with me that
the AOE heal is a good skill because we
can actually see how often it uses
teammate yeah I saved him right there uh
at least for a second I saved him
Towers look at this guy how is he it's
like this one is teleporting somehow I
don't actually there is not an ability
that does this in the game so I think
it's found some way to abuse
something like yeah they're just running
down mid but they're actually kind of
doing stuff as well so I think this is
pretty good this is like a good
result oh look you can see I got I got
slowed here you saw the move
counter oh they oneshot me don't they
[ __ ] the level like the high level just
ones shots you somehow I've gotten to
level 11 doing what I've been
doing I kind of want to just finish the
game out to see what
happens come
on there's also there's no respawn timer
at the moment which probably shifts
things quite a
okay jez I think the meta for this is
like so fast that you have to just
like oh they tried to we're still
losing wait is our Tower dead here but
like still on the board
that's
weird yeah that's weird for
sure I think there's uh there might be a
few bugs that we'll have to find it does
work
jeez so I think even with me playing
here we're still losing to this
right which means I guess the Bots are
kind of good yeah he just like ran by
and like drive by merked to me there
let's see if we can be smart and win by
being clever can I like back
door let's see if I can like back door
this oh I cannot back door this it takes
it does way too much damage
wait how is this oh no wait that Tower
is supposed to be there
H level
25 we have a big boy here level
25 okay we saved our level 13 for a
second we just sit here spamming heals
for as long as we
can level 14 I just saw they have a
level
27 so I'm assuming that's like the
assassin class or like whichever one's
super broken at the moment
I got slowed
there with a big uh a big effect and now
I'm back to normal speed can I save some
of
these Tower just like one shot me
oh and their game's over so I guess we
lost or we won I can't
tell uh assumedly I think we lost cuz
they had I don't think unless they
killed the we killed the ancient and I
didn't see it but okay there you go
that's that's the game that is
a 6,000 tick
game
cool that was fun um let's see let's see
what uh what the agent thinks of our
strategy it says that the Q is very
good what about
W okay it agrees with us it used its W
times it didn't use its e at all okay I
agree and it used it just Q 500 times so
interestingly I think that we spam heals
more than I think that this thing was
just using more
damage but we'll go look at stuff now so
this actually the policy is reasonable
it's kind of just like run it down mid
but it is using skills and it seems to
have identified like strong skills and
stuff so it seems to actually be doing
okay
a I guess we just start opening up the
code and we start looking at skills
huh I I do want to post the results of
this sweep though cuz this is actually a
really cool demonstration of
what happened shouldn't it this one
right
here how many actual experiments was
this let's see if we can figure it out
internet's not down what the hell's
wrong with
this I want to post this
steps I mean this has got to be greater
than has got to be greater than like a
trillion steps isn't it wait let me
think no greater than 100 billion I
think not a
trillion cuz if I'm training
well I'm at least doing a billion per
hour and I ran this thing for like 4
days yeah so it's like 100 billion
let's get our screenshot and then stop
lagging our
teleporting is there anything else cool
I
so here's where this is going to be
actually useful for us I'm going put
this on the other monitor so I can
reference
it h it'll be easier to view if I just
alt tab a bunch so we'll do this yeah so
Huffer lib environments ocean MOBA Coba
we open up the
source and we go look at skill
you can see we have all the skills here
and here are the
implementations so now what we get to do
is we get to see which of these are
op and which of these need to be
buffed I'm trying to think if there's
anything else we can do along the
way probably the easiest thing to do for
this round will be to
uh start from the previous best hyper
parameters as like the initialization or
whatever well I
think we kind of got good policies
within like a 100 experiments didn't
we
relatively it would be nice if we had a
way to like start from the old bests and
then search from
there it's something I got to try with
carbs is like a way to do that
I don't
know maybe there will be a way to do
that we'll I'll have to think about that
actually maybe that's not too
hard you see what I mean like it's um it
would be really nice if we could like
take some of these points that were good
in the previous run and use these as the
initial settings for the new run or
whatever but we'll think about that
later for now like we'll keep going here
so
usage okay so support Q oh that's really
interesting so I forgot about this um it
technically support technically has a
hook
but according to this this ability is
very
good they're probably hooking Towers or
something but um I guess we'll leave
this for now because it says that this
is a good
ability it says our W is a good ability
I agree this was the AOE heal it seems
very
strong um interestingly it says that the
stun is not very good
effect that's like a ridiculous ly
strong stun effect
actually it could be just because um the
way it works at the moment is I think
you target the closest
opponent so it could just be hard to
land I think we'll have to
do hold on you should not be able to
chain this either currently this is like
literally infinitely chainable it's
literally infinitely chainable and it's
still not getting
used wait
Mana I guess you don't have any followup
of your own right yeah yeah wait wait so
the support doesn't have any damage
abilities of its own that's got to be it
right so it doesn't have any
followup let's do like let's let's
change this to 30 Mana for
now um I actually want to increase this
to like 60 you can still infinitely
chain it at 60
but we'll do 30 Mana at least for
now we'll see if they use a a giant ass
stun at 30
mana and we'll also see if anybody else
has stuns that they're actually using
cuz they were using
slows maybe everything has to be AOE
until they get better targeting
abilities we'll
see okay uh let's go to burst
garbage hang on how is this class
bad do its abilities not just
scale well hold on this maybe this isn't
bad this is an expensive ability right
this a 60 mana
ability how much did uh the support use
its abilities
400 yeah so
400 400 uses for 40
Mana I think that's where most of it
Mana was
maybe it just doesn't like these really
high Mana cost
abilities you can technically I did it
this way intentionally so you could
chain it
down let's take this down to
50 let's just give it a little bit of
help and maybe this will make it a
little bit more commonly used wait it
says it
uses oh it does use its AOE stun quite a
ability and it doesn't use its burst AOE
like at
all really
creep oh wait creep. health is 450 I
think I forgot to rebalance this from
before 500 plus player
level yeah so we don't want this to be
able to literally one shot
fine we have to add scaling to these
abilities I think at some
point that's going to be hard but we're
we're going to have to do this at some
point I think what we can do is we can
initially let's like let's do this we'll
run an additional sweep and then we'll
do some more experimental stuff Stu so
we'll do this this can go up to 300 AOE
damage uh for 30
Mana like this so this gets a pretty
substantial buff and then this one I
like this stun I think this is in a good
spot
already and then let's see uh tank is
next
what it really likes this Q
ability I'm actually I'm wondering if
this tank queue ability was the thing
that was letting it
like no this was not the thing that was
letting it jump this is just an AOE
this is a channeled AOE
right it does what's that 20 damage for
five
Mana so 400 damage for your whole bar
but it's
channeled oh hold on it's it's using it
800 times but it only costs five Mana
this is fine this is
balanced we got to change like the usage
to like Mana spent or something instead
yeah we're going to want to clean up
some of this code here so it's easier to
track stuff like that okay it says that
the interestingly it says it's w is very
good it might be teleporting weirdly
here right
jumping it was jumping way more often
though than it would be regening that
Mana I think it it's probably not this
ability I don't know
this seems like it's strong but I don't
know how to change it yeah yeah no this
has a very long cool down as
well
huh
Q oh wait wait no no no I read this
wrong hold on let me make sure I did the
previous ones
correct oh yeah I messed up didn't
I wait hold
on wait burst AO e let me see if I did
this one
right
qw wait qw and
E so I
was I was increasing this burst AOE
which is its W no it's already using
it's already using its
W quite a lot
yeah it's not using its AOE stun at
all okay let's go back up here let's
undo these changes cuz I obviously I
read this wrong we're going to have to
go back through
this I really should be more careful
with these um so but we can go faster
now so support Q it's using its hook
cool I don't know why but it is W it is
using using its AOE heal e it's stun
it's not using we actually we did this
this first one correctly we increased
the Mana we decrease the Mana cost of
this stun
right
burst is it's using its
Q its Q
is fine not amazing
maybe we can give it a well it's it's
maybe its best skill q and it's w it's
using so it's using its nuke and its AOE
but not its stun at all okay so in that
case I think we will we will
leave we'll leave everything except
we'll uh we'll just decrease its cool
down on this a little
bit maybe just leave it as
is and let's really focus on the stun
this it's really not valuing stuns like
at
all okay so this goes to 30 mana and to
a uh a substantially lower cool down I
guess I don't know why that's like
really bizarre that it's not using this
this is I thought this is a very strong
ability the agents
disagree and then
tank this ability is it yeah the
channeled AOE this is like a channeled
AOE
damage this one is
fine W which is the second one okay this
one is also very strong already so
thankfully we didn't buff this you can
see it uses itself heal a lot and the
only one it doesn't it doesn't do is its
e ability
here uh which is just an
engage
so I think that this one if it's going
to be useful we're just going to have to
like make it massively
cheaper so we'll see if it's good at uh
you know what we can actually do with
this we can keep the exact same hyper
parameters as before and we can just run
this with the after the balance changes
it's not going to be perfect because we
didn't retune hypers but at least it
will give us some idea
okay so it's saying that this carry
really only has one good skill
huh so this Retreat slow apparently
sucks um it's w is good and then it's e
is
garbage
huh
doesn't the burst have its it's like the
exact same skill This is 40 Mana for 200
AOE and then the burst
has 40 Mana for 200 AOE it has like the
same
skill so wait was the burst was using
this
yeah it was using this ability that's
weird but the carry
wasn't is one of its other skills like
really
good how much is its W 40 Mana 300
times really likes this
ability I got hit with this a few times
actually
this just does it does 100
damage and it
slows and it has applies like a long
slow
okay so I guess let's first try buffing
the other two abilities
abilities and I don't even know how good
these classes are relative to each other
because we have to add more logging but
like what we'll do is we'll like these
experiments only take like 10 15 minutes
to run so we can actually do a bunch of
iterating today let's see just like how
far how far we can get into balancing
this MOA like without redoing hyper
parameter sweeps just by like messing
with skills and uh going from there I
bet we can actually do this like pretty
darn fast which is kind of cool if you
think about it for like automatically
balancing games
right that's actually really
sweet if this works well I I won't post
anything about this until if it works
though today like that's kind of a huge
deal for auto balance in games right you
just like RL a game and then you just
tweak it and you do it again and if it
runs fast enough you're just you're good
to go
that's really
cool
slow it doesn't like this
ability it's a defensive
ability I guess it just doesn't do
damage
let's Okay what we're going to do is
we're going to we're going to change it
to 10 Mana from
20 and
it I guess it's a defensive tool so I
wouldn't be surprised if it doesn't
learn to do this we'll just do that for
now and let's see if we can get the uh
qw wait
Q wait did I do it
again no we're good so it says it's Q is
bad which is this it's w here is good
which we we left alone and then it's e
it uses a little bit but but not a
lot this is kind of weird
though because the burst uses this
skill I guess it just doesn't like this
as much as it's
slow but that's weird so for 40 Mana it
would rather do 100 damage and slow than
do 200 damage in AOE
huh we might have to Nerf that thing
then but it doesn't look like it's that
broken to me we'll change this to 30
what is it we'll change this to 20
Mana to see and we'll change it to 250
or no
300 and we'll see what that does
one round of like random balancing like
this just to see what a difference it
makes will be
good and then
holy doesn't use its
Q doesn't really use its
W uses all its mana on its e
so I'm not surprised that it really
likes its um its
e so it's e is a move buff it's a
channeled move buff that
um I mean this is a crazy amount of
usage I guess it's just using this to
get to the like to get the reward to get
for the other side though
this skill is strong is it that
strong it costs a
lot it's possible that it's like
Feathering
ability right so we'll do
player. qwe
timer be
10 move timer is going to be
10 and then it goes to 50
Mana I think this will feel worse to
play we'll do it for now but the channel
move buff just felt so damn good
though I really don't want to change
this just cuz like this was like of all
the stuff I did like this is so basic
but it like it felt so good to play this
you
know I think the most I want to do is
increase the Mana
cost so we'll do like
10 and then I thought its other
abilities were like really strong
400 will nerf the Mana
cost and then the Assassin TP
damage dude this ability should be so
freaking strong already I should not
have to be changing this I like it's
just spending all its mana on other
stuff there's no
way I mean this does
damage and it's like a blink
strike but also like I don't have any
scaling on these abilities yet so maybe
later in the game it's just
useless I mean it's not never using this
right it has a few uses of
it so maybe if we just like Nerf the
Mana cost on this right down to like 30
it'll be happy spending mana on this it
just like really wants its Mana for that
move
buff okay so we'll try
today Mom set up do
Pi build
next how is the skill distribution
initialized even if they have different
cooldowns there should be a metric to
normalize their usage count
right
[Music]
um that's what we're going to do while
this thing is training we're going to
think about that give me one second
I want to get this thing to train
first okay so this should Now train uh
I'm going to leave this on the other
monitor so I think what we want
is the thing is they cost different
amounts of mana and they have different
cool downs and stuff right like you
said do we want to track amount of Mana
spent on skill is that what we want
or do we want to track like usage count
is the number of times you press the
button which
is also
interesting I think regardless that the
thing that I really want that we don't
have right now is I want to know I want
to know what level all the different
classes are I really want to know what
level the different classes are so we
we've got like 10 minutes while this
thing trains
let's track
um let's track
Q
uses
of o0 to
level and this is right isn't
it
yeah
five support assassin burst
tank yeah so this is the indexing for
this that was easier than expected
what else can we log
here to help us
understand damage
inflicted we just need to add like more
log metrics basically
the classic ones in Dota like total
damage inflicted is a good metric
maybe let's do
damage
inflicted Heroes
killed
sustain what do you mean sustainable
target. Health minus equal damage
player. damage inflicted plus equal
damage
and then if Target type
is entity
player we do player. hero kill plus
one I always think it's going to be like
hard to add features and then I remember
that when I'm writing the code AS brain
dead as I'm currently writing it it's
actually incredibly
easy like literally everything is just
one struct and I just add more members
to a struct
great what are the Met like what are
like the DOTA is it like DOTA buff
metrics or like DOTA buff what metrics
do they have on
here I'm just like looking for
inspiration of stuff that like I should
log
here game
impact this looks
good
damage
healing oh I should track damage and
healing separately right
it is a lot of pre-planning that does
work when that
happens
this adding stuff to Spaghetti cat is
impossible the funny thing is like
I don't know maybe I've it's just
because I've been doing this for so long
but the way the thing that finally
clicked for me with writing these
projects is like just brain off stop
trying to be clever write the code in
the stupidest simplest way possible just
super procedural like everything all the
everything is just an entity an entity
is a giant struct you can put as much
stuff into that one struct as possible
it doesn't matter it's nicely laid out
in contiguous memory it's like G to be
super fast you can just add more [ __ ] to
the struct and like write your code
really dumb simple procedural like no
abstractions
whatsoever and it's just like incredibly
nice to be able to work that
way it's like all the nicely abstracted
code that ends up being spaghetti that's
impossible to change
ironically so economy doesn't matter I
guess XP but we're going to get that
from
Level denies gold per
minute Vision doesn't affect this
yet I think we just do healing is like
the one other thing since we do have
support characters
well oh we could do damage dealt Dam or
damage inflicted or damage dealt damage
received uh healing dealt healing
received right and that gives this a
nice
picture let's do that real quick
just to show you how brain dead the
design of this thing is like look it's
just a struct the struct is an entity
everything's an entity I don't care if
it's a creep and it only uses like a few
of these we don't care
like in
damage
dealt int damage
received and healing
dealt and healing
received layer
dot damage
delt that's
it okay and then here all we do
let me figure out where this is
implemented scan
AOE AOE scanned oh yeah right here so
there's a there's a heal function
so all we have to
do I bet most of the DOTA code is
written like that I bet it's
not usually you don't see this written
like this is not how big teams will work
on
projects like
ever my solution to this is to Simply
never work on large projects I just work
on mediumsized projects and I make them
very simple and very
good can do plenty ofu stuff with
this though I'm getting better at like
I'm getting better at scaling stuff to
large projects without making a
mess pretty proud of
that
okay inflicted so here we just do
player. damage dealt right and target.
damage received
this does Overkill
technically do we want to account for
fine kiro's
killed creeps
killed Towers killed and new trolls
right okay so we'll just do
LF it
is target. entity
type the
creep Target creeps killed Plus plus
equal
one
kill neutral
kill
Tower
kill few more lines of code but very
easy to
read if player. entity type okay this is
different oh and then this is supposed
to be
player player. Towers killed
bad and then we do here
is player. Heroes
killed plus equal one
right damage dealt damage received
Heroes killed this is all good and now
we just have to do void heal be heal
yeah
here so right
here now all we have to do is
this should be a
float
and this is perfect timing because the
other training run just
finished so let's see if it crashes
first of all
okay doesn't at least at least it does
not crash initially we'll give it a few
seconds to see if it kills some minions
if it
crashes nope looks
and perfect this is what we were looking
for
so let's see if we have had any effect
whatsoever on The
Meta let's see if our balance change has
actually shifted The
Meta this is so
q q is about the
same oops I got to like oh wait my
camera's over this isn't
it hold
29 okay they don't love
it but it went
up right it went up quite substantially
and then support
W is about the same okay so you know we
we at least made a skill somewhat
burst I think this is let me see so Q is
160 same
okay
e 97 they like this skill
now they like this
skill and W is 65 so maybe they just
like split their usage a little
bit balanced class
Q okay it still hates this
skill it still hates this
skill what about the E it likes this
skill and the W it likes this skill so
if I recall this is like this is like a
defensive ability that would be kind of
hard to learn how to use so that's going
to be tough for us to evaluate but it
has two two viable skills
Assassin assassin
W same as before
trying to remember what this was I think
that this was just like a minion clear
ability maybe this has to be much more
powerful I don't know about this one um
but the main
thing okay it still does not like its Q
interesting I think that it its like e
ability is just so incredibly powerful
like it really really likes this
movement ability here you can see it's
about half of what it was before because
I doubled the Mana cost but it's still
going to use it and I think that reason
for that is that we're directly
rewarding it for going to the enemy
ancient so it's kind of just greedy
right it's like oh I can get to the
enemy ancient faster right not use any
of my other skills so I don't know about
that one we'll have to think about that
um I'm hesitant to Nerf it because it's
a really fun
ability like it's really fun to just be
able to go turbo
tank
is W is
same tank Q is
same ah it likes this ability
now dude that is awesome so
basically we just by looking at these
log metrics we made some tweaks and the
agents learned a new meta in 15
minutes isn't that
powerful could you imagine being like a
little Indie Game Dev I mean obviously
like your game's probably not going to
run fast enough unless you design it
with this in mind but if you did Imagine
just like Auto balancing your game like
this like not having to wait 3 months
for players to like play your game and
say hey this is kind ofo too strong on
the forms and stuff yeah that's
cool
words I don't know if that's supposed to
be like yeah word or I don't
know welcome
though this is
cool okay so I think what we can do now
is let's push the new code and uh we're
going to train the new code while we
play with this model and see if it's any
good and see if we can find more bugs
to pull origin
Dev on set up high build X place
right yeah and
then I want this command I'm going to
run this in t-o this
time
t-o okay
let me see if it at least
runs because we did add some logging
Shenanigans look at all that extra
stuff oh we forgot to uh we forgot to
expose it hold
on we forgot to expose
hi
okay so here we need to
do mge
delt SL
support image
received uh this indexing is kind of
Jank we should probably just take a
second to do um to do this properly
right it won't won't take me more than a
of oh I don't know if I can index it
this way hold
on it it's worth me taking a second to
do this correctly because otherwise it's
like we're doing this indexing a million
times and it's going to slow us down
go self. entities star oh I didn't even
realize I'm running like 200 games or 20
games or whatever this is
uh five
perfect so this gives
you yeah this is exactly what we want
and then can I do dot damage
dealt
perfect so this is a kind of cool trick
um I have these like structured numpy
arrays that kind of act like well
they're strs but you can slice them and
you can do notation index them so I can
just do like support equal self.
entities of uh
colon and now you see I have all of the
different classes in here
and now all I have to do
is
mean port. damage
dealt is that
simple and now you can literally just
tab complete everything because it's so
dealt uh I don't like the way that it I
don't quite like the way that it did
this though I'd prefer that it it
grouped each
stat damage dealt
assassin burst
carry damage
received yeah it keeps it likes to do
this weird thing it likes to interl them
I don't like
that
[Music]
assassin infos healing
delt and now it'll auto complete for us
[Music]
uh this is exactly what I love um this
is my preferred use of language models
as well like completing brain dead [ __ ]
but not really writing any logic for you
I think this is a this is a very nice
addition to
workflow damage dealt damage received
now we need level
and let's do all the
cues usage support
Q do we want to do qwe
qwe I guess this is fine
clean obviously it's a bunch of metrix
but
that's nice and
simple just a bunch of means over
arrays all the indexing is right here
it's very very rare that I find um an
abstraction that I like I think is worth
the extra overhead of the weight but
like the numpy structured array API is
just so good I mean it's like I guess I
would I'd like convenient lowlevel data
structures I find those to be useful
abstractions so just like like having a
data structure that can have in
contiguous memory like a list or what is
it an array of structs but then being
able to access like the same property of
the whole array or like slice the array
and then access the property it's like
perfect and you can even do it with 2D
arrays as well or ND
arrays I really like that oh look at
that another twitch
ban twitch has really got to
um fix that problem like I don't get
that on YouTube and I have like more I
have like all the viewers are on
YouTube twitch has got to fix
get pull origin
Dev don't need to
rebuild should probably increase the
size of this
right
holy lot of
stats but look at the amount of data you
get out of that Holy that is amazing
oh I see it's the the order that you log
them in it's going back and forth like
this that's why it's not we could fix
that so that it gives us stats in a nice
order we'll leave this for now though um
okay I'm going to use a restro real
quick and then we're going to play with
the model a bit while we wait for this
to train fix some more bugs I think
we're just going to keep iterating like
this
and I wouldn't be surprised we actually
end up with like a reasonably balanced
game by the end of
today I'll be right
I should have Discord
open' been getting some report some uh
support requests from some of the
contributors let me go check something
real quick
alive we're alive but my camera is
frozen I
see is the microphone working it looks
like it
kind of let me fix
that your camera died yeah yeah yeah
hold
it uh okay that didn't fix it let
me check what the heck
go puffer
support no sweep using 1em for debugging
oops Mike yes we're good right
yeah we're
back
okay well this is cool to
see yep yep
okay damage received
who look at this you can actually see
like which classes are going to be op
and
stuff burst and carryer like a way
higher level that's
fun so we'll be able to do a lot from
this tank is just self healing a
ton we'll basically just be able to play
with these numbers until like the stats
of the classes look like the stats the
classes are supposed to look like right
maybe we have to replace a skill or two
maybe we'll see but um it's pretty
good let's go play with the
um let's go play with this in the
meantime we'll see what's up
ah okay I actually kept the team alive
there with the the
heals okay but I did not survive
that I don't know what's wrong with the
neutrals they're just like not spawning
or
something doesn't really matter for this
format but it will matter in the future
W's okay W is on cool down I have to be
careful the cool Down's pretty long so I
can combo like w I
think come on
W okay healed e they're going to kill me
aren't they
yeah is there puffer stuck here
was just a
minion all
right we should write like the class or
something under the
name maybe I can tell like do you see
this thing that's like
jumping I'll have to figure out what
that is
okay we healed uh our Ally along the way
there was not fast enough to get the
heal in or maybe it was just on cool
down it's going to need some animations
and like some better graphics and stuff
but so far this is getting
better it's getting much better
3 minutes left on the
experiment I will uh put this up here
and then while I'm waiting for stuff I
will either answer some questions or
look at some support stuff for Puffer
interesting that it's less
stable I mean this could just be
different hypers
though probably needs more entropy bonus
it looks
fracks and P conflict this is
fine this is
[Music]
this this is Pokemon guys spamming the
hell out of my Dev
chat though I tell them not to do that
let me see I don't think I'm missing a
meeting
right probably chat with Joseph on his
stream that's fine by me
uh what where is
15K m is 11 num workers is 11 M batch
size one
the
heck what m is this
uh I'm assuming this is snake yeah pr.
device
CPU oh and kyung has code as well okay
one sec kyung um
and yeah we'll check your thing right
now
people were asking by the way about uh
robotics M so uh on stream so people are
definitely interested in this
stuff clean rlpp to use the same config
and
policy well it's not going to match
perfectly K like there are substantial
implementation differences J is one um
the way we handle our data trajectory
segments is
different like there are a lot of things
that could be different
here of course I mean they're always
possible that there are
like uh minor bugs or things to be
improved but there are just going to be
implementation differences so it's very
likely that just the optimal hyper
parameters are going to vary um do you
have specific stuff for me to look at
config is this your
config oh you made it a this is not a
toml this
isn't I guess it is technically it's
like an any file
but and if you're using the same prams
for each yeah I mean looking at the
policy like it looks to me like probably
entropy needs to be get get bumped up a
little and maybe learning rate needs to
go down a little bit but like I can't
really tell I how fast does this run
steps per second cuz like I me if you
run this thing at I think you said 30
40,000 steps per second like 2 million
total time steps you can run 100
experiment
sweep 1.1k
how is it that
slow how the heck is it that
slow one word okay yeah so I would just
get get good settings and then like run
the hypers sweep unless you suspect that
there's like literally a bug with the
continuous
integration I would generally try to
like get it to be fast the thing is
there's no way to check the
implementation cuz like this is not a
thing in RL implementations are not
going to match like imple
implementations of the the same
algorithm just based on very minor
differences are going to have
dramatically different performance and
dramatically different optimal hyper
parameters
so unless you're like explicitly trying
to make sure two implementations are
identical or something yeah it looks
like the policy collapse yeah I mean
that happens all the time in RL right
like bad hyper parameters will just make
policies collapse if you look at any of
our sweeps like any of our sweeps you'll
see that there are experiments in those
sweeps in which the thing just
crashes see was it the was it the one
you linked me
here okay for stream we'll do a quick
little debug sesh
here so
steps it's kind of interesting because
the average reward seems to be going
up is there something weird here because
like the average reward is going
up or it's like
flat so there's something kind of weird
with this environment
I mean this is not like necessarily
egregiously bad K like I can see that
this clip fraction has exploded the
value loss is still technically fine
policy loss is blowing up a bit here
which leads to like learning rate being
bad oh entropy is totally crashed yeah
this
is how is entropy
negative wait I entropy shouldn't be
able to be negative right
you might want to check the entropy
implementation for um continuous actions
I don't know if I handled
that double check on that is this a
thing if you look at clean RLS is this
is this
negative entropy can be
negative okay what do I know it's not
negative for discret values right or am
I just
dumb I thought it's p log
okay no only for okay well I have an
excuse then I've literally like never
bothered working with continuous Ms so
fine um if it's about the same as clean
RL then
sure I mean like Kung this is not
egregiously bad this is just like
something that has slightly off hyper
parameters it looks like uh does carb
sweep work with this environment because
if it works and if you can run this at
like 30k plus you'll be able to run a
100 experiment sweep in like a few hours
so you can literally just do that
today I've basically just stopped
manually thinking about hyper parameters
because like even with all the RL I've
done over the last 7 years
like carbs just finds better stuff than
I
can I wanted to check the implementation
before sweeps do both at the same time
if the sweeps fails I would actually no
I do it the opposite way I would like
optimize throughput so you're like
simulating enough M's in parallel and
then I would run the carb sweep and if
the carb sweep doesn't find anything
good then I'd suspect the implementation
it's kind of cool that you can do this
now but like carbs is good enough that
as long as you have initial initial set
of hyper parameters that at least learn
something like you can kind of assume
that if carbs doesn't solve it then
something is broken it's that good like
I don't know if you've seen what I've
been doing today but
literally I have an optimized carb set
of hyper parameters here and I'm just
like looking at what the agents are
doing looking at the skills that they're
using going to the mooba rebalancing the
skills based on which ones they're using
and which ones they're not rerunning
training and like going back and forth
and just Auto balancing the game with RL
like carbs finds really really good
prams and they're like crazy prams I'd
never think of it sometimes as
well so yeah there you go that's my
suggestion go try that and then come
back if that does not work I'm here all
forward to pass batch size based on
Hardware
based on that oh wait Noah you're on the
stream perfect so I can just talk if
you're still here
um yeah we'll we'll I'll take a couple
minutes to fix uh fix like viewers and
contributor stuff so uh Noah the way
that you want to look at this when you
have when you're in fast environments
land you're usually going to want a
forward pass batch size of at least
4096 so 4096 copies of the environment
um per batch and then you want an
asynchronicity Factor on top of that of
for fast environments you can often get
away with exactly
two um so let's say that you have 4 uh
81 92 total Ms being simulated and
you're using uh 496 of them each time if
the N is fast enough then which let me
see it looks to me like your EnV is fast
enough to do this because it's over a
million steps per second you should just
be able to do two
cores um 4096 environments per
core and your forward PR batch size is
4096 and then obviously your train batch
size is going to be much higher that's
what I would sort of start off
with does that make sense
SCP where's the the SCP command from
before I lose
it I want to have to Reem oh there it
is
o119 PT is that it
nice so we got our
model and then we can potentially
run
evals we can run evals with this but
first we let's get some mileage out of
these
stats
wait what's the the t-u command to let
me scroll I just
forget contrl B and then okay the wrong
bracket I was
so if it will let me scroll up
to
stats this is like a lot a lot of cool
stats
honestly so right off the
bat the support is supposed to be a
lower level than the rest of the team
but it's not supposed to be that
low-leveled and the reason for this is
is probably that you're only getting XP
on last hit not in like
that it seems like
the the burst and the carry are way
overpowered compared to everyone
else like the damage dealt being double
is a lot but like the the main thing is
the level difference I
think uh the support did 100K healing
though that's like huge
right the tank
did the tank actually does 150k healing
the tank even does more healing though
that's purely selfhealing
so I think mostly the supports just
healing
itself it's not great you do see the
burst
carry you do see the other classes are
getting some healing and I think there's
only one AOE heal in the game and it's
the supports so that like 4K healing is
uh from the support
dealt I'm surprised how low damage the
assassin class is as well as the
tank H
interesting so I guess we got to make
some decisions from here right like
only getting XP on last hit is that
terrible game
design is only getting L is only getting
XP on last hit terrible game design
bit I'm trying to think what would
happen with that
like what would happen if in Dota you
only
got XP on last
hit I would not be a main support player
well like would the meta just change
though because you probably don't want
to have like a completely useless hero
that's that far behind right so like
maybe it's just going to be instead of
hey don't ever take any of my kills like
maybe the support is supposed to take
you know some fraction of the kills
instead right some fraction of the last
XP I spend a lot of time kiting oh right
right right
these guys haven't figured out the
laning stage at all though like that yet
they're literally just like running at
each other down mid at the
moment ideally the carry should have the
kills yeah well the carry does have the
kills the carry is apparently op right
now there's no gold in this we didn't do
item buy there is XP and leveling
though I don't think we have spell
scaling yet
either so we need to add some more
scaling before we can really
tell the level discrepancy is very large
though
to it's probably only like 20 lines of
code
to do XP
split I'm trying to think if it's worth
doing is it worth doing shared
XP up to
you well the thing is I just don't know
yet like with the game
um I guess it's just for the sake of
being closer to
DOTA turn-based
this is not turn-based
a turn-based Sim would be really cool
though like a crpg style like turnbas
Sim that would be a really good
environment honestly like that's what a
lot of people call RTS in RL
anyways turn based tactical games were
like some of my favorites growing up as
well
received they all kind of received the
same amount of damage didn't
they metagrid yeah hey David
welcome
yeah I if you want to look at like
actually I thought of this David if you
want to look at like a really freaking
intricate
um grid grid based games there are two
MMOs that are both technically grid
based RuneScape is technically grid
based so all of RuneScape is technically
grid based and the other one that's like
more like turn-based grid based is where
is this it's it has Silly artwork
because French people are
silly um can I find good pictures of
this
yeah it has very silly artwork because
French damn it where's
the okay yeah this is what it looks like
no where's
the the combat
icon I mean it kind of looks like Fire
Emblem doist wakoo
yeah I mean this is a very hard one to
implement but yeah it looks like this
oops
it looks like this where like you know
you have spells and stuff you it's like
a turn-based environment they're
obstacles and it's like this is an
MMO tablin have you heard of this if so
I'm actually kind of surprised very few
people have heard of
this I probably have 3 to 4,000 hours in
this game though the vast majority of
from when I'm younger old patch yeah I
played pre uh pre
1.29 well you said doe is walk fu yeah
not many people in the US have heard of
this
game but it's a really cool
game
um it's also essentially heroin for me
which is why I'm not allowed to play
it that and runscape are like the two
biggest time syncs I've ever
seen it was the hot thing really that's
awesome I was basically the only one I
actually knew in person that ever played
it but you know the darnest thing
happened like oh EU viewer that's why
okay so in the US like nobody had heard
of this played it today dang
okay then I get to show off a little bit
of game cred with this I had back in
like 20 when would it have
been 2007 whenever one point whenever
like frig was around like early frig I
had like a team of I think four and it
eventually grew to five like one nx's
I'd like I was like maging gear for half
the server I had I had a lot of cool
stuff going on and then I went back to
the game two separate times and made
like level 200
fun it's an awesome game and they
yeah there's one other thing with it
what
else oh yeah yeah so this is the coolest
thing that happened this is incredibly
random but so basically nobody I knew in
person played this thing right cuz like
very uncommon in the US but there's one
guy that I played this thing for like
you know thousands of hours with I knew
one guy really well from the game and
then like you know I got busy with like
actual work stuff so I stopped playing
it he stopped playing it and then but
like I knew his name and stuff so then I
randomly while I was in Boston I found
him on
LinkedIn turns out he's like he now
works uh he's now a software engineer so
I actually met up with him and now like
he moved to California as well so now we
hang out isn't that
nutty I don't know games games create
weird stuff it's fun play the Retro
version
okay I actually I really didn't like
where it was in the non retro version
for a long time but then like I think
that they recently made the newer
versions good again they like walked
back a bunch of the bad changes that
they'd made and it's actually the newer
version is good as well now now the
Retro version was good as well but like
man I remember being super young and
trying to like spend like four hours
trying to recruit a group to do a
dungeon or whatever only to wipe on the
boss and there to be no save system and
you know trying to get everybody keys
and all that
nonsense there was like zero
Q anyways that's enough about that's
enough about that but that's actually
really cool to see that people are
people have heard of that game
oh the misery oh man I remember it would
always be like trying to recruit for
like I think greater BB was the thing
I'd like I don't
know maybe I maybe I was clever or maybe
I just thought I was clever but I would
come up with all sorts of ridiculous
things
like I found a way to one turn the
greater BB uh with like one character I
had like a 12 AP character with a crazy
stuff wand which hits twice for 2 AP so
you could do 12 fire damage hits on it
in one turn which like the way that that
boss works it gets more it gets weaker
the more times you hit it so you just be
like hitting it for thousands and
thousands in just one turn it was
awesome retro is only eight accounts now
uh if they actually had like built-in
good multi cening support and like
leaned into it I'd actually be down with
that I don't think eight though eight is
like unless you had really good account
management eight is too much I think
it's way more fun to do like four and
four so you play with like one other
person and you do like eight teams
yeah okay Damian here's asking real
questions we got distracted by games
would puffer work on my Mac Pro M1 yeah
like it'll work on anything it's just
like it's going to be as fast as it can
be for your Hardware right I have people
training we actually do have a few
environments even this one would be fast
like this MOBA that I've been playing
with would be
fast like the new M I'm writing with
puffer they all run at a million plus
steps per second and even if you're
training on CPU like a good CPU should
still train over a
100,000 which for context like people
spend spend years like doing experiments
on environments that run at 2,000 SPS or
less so yeah this is it's nice and fast
let's do a little bit of uh a little bit
of balancing here so I think that we
should
actually I have no idea what the boss
names are in English okay we'll talk
about this stuff but I'm going to also
I'm going to also start fixing things at
the same time um doofus PVP en okay if
you actually want to do that I would be
down to like help you very
substantially with that because man I
would love that to exist
I'd be way down to help with that like
I'd C like I'd Cod like just online I
just like code stuff with you on that
that sounds awesome finish your initial
end first though cuz like yeah finish
your initial end
first I'm I guarantee you I could make
that game a million FPS in like pure C
maybe we'd have to pre-compute some
bounce like some site checks or whatever
but yeah a million FPS and C at least
soon as pong works
yeah that's so cool that like rogue
agent doing bomb walls oh that'd be so
cool
man so I guess since I'm getting
distracted here anyways I want to share
like I don't know if this is common
knowledge it's in my thesis but like who
the hell reads like a whole PhD thesis
the original motivation for neural MMO
was that I and I still genuinely think
this I think that like MMOs are one of
the best ways to get us to artificial
general
intelligence and that might sound crazy
but like think about it of every single
type of fast simulator that we know how
to build like it's MMOs right giant
worlds tons of players persistent
gameplay lots and lots of different
activities you know dynamically forming
economies that that kind of behave with
realistic supply and demand like and you
can run these things crazy fast cuz they
were designed to run thousands of
players on '90s Hardware
right that was the original motivation
for neural MMO and I still think that we
can do that though it is quite hard and
uh you know short term I am making a
bunch of these Sims but I also do need
to find a way to get puffer lib to
actually bring in some Revenue so I can
continue scaling hardware for this
stuff I have your defense in my back
back
log the video is worth
watching the video is worth watching the
whole thesis document
like uh it's 170
Pages honestly
like my work really isn't that technical
on the science side like I started off
very science and math heavy and then I
slowly went more and more engineering
ing heavy over the years just because
that's what kept
working so like it's the type of thing
we now like maybe if you don't have a
ton of engineering experience you
wouldn't be able to like design the way
in which these M's are set up such that
they're this fast or like such that they
work this clearly with the RL stack but
if you have that you can totally build
cool stuff on top of
it all the resourceful people say
I possess a unique set of skills we can
say
that I have a certain set of
skills you're better than you think I'm
not being humble I'm not humble in the
least I'm actually very arrogant but
um like my work I do think is generally
more accessible in the sense that like
you can at least look through stuff and
understand it cuz it's not a ton of math
and it's not like a ton of very obscure
reason Arch you might not understand
like the exact motivation for why
everything is done the specific way but
you can kind of follow the code and see
like oh okay this is relatively simple
and I see I see that this is fast right
and I see that I could use the same
thing to make other things fast as well
we have to at least Implement a feature
now one at least one feature per hour
right before we get too
moaing doofus pvpn would be so
sick you know that my main thing lately
is I've just been pitching random grad
students I'm like hey hey we should
build we should build a cool simulator
and then you could do RL on it and you
could like publish some cool work and
I'll help a lot with
it cuz that's the main thing I want to
do with puffer at this point is like
just build a ton of
Sims did I totally screw up my
stream oh no it's
fine all right let's do
um let's do XP sharing let's do XP
sharing and then we'll rerun training
and we'll see if the levels are more
balanced that's what we'll do
I want oh yeah I missed that message
David
so I think I saw that you'd like built
something with that so David the reason
that I haven't released that as a
standalone yet is that the
implementation is very fast but it's
kind of Jank like I don't think that
we're properly handling like episode and
segment bounds and such in there so like
I
think there are definitely some like
degeneracies Poss possible with that
implementation if you wanted to like
look at it and like
actually like take the time to fix or
like to check the implementation and see
if it could be improved then yeah it
could be very useful to have like
Standalone J if you're just looking to
have something that's easier to build in
your project yeah you can feel free to
like stick it in a setup.py or whatever
for now but I think for it to be more
useful broadly
um yeah we would have to do
we'd have to do some checking on it
because it's kind of weird the way it
works J might be a good candidate for
puffer li. C
okay so right here is where we want to
calculate XP sharing
right sounds good it's in fast J for now
and we can revisit does that mean clean
puff orl is is broken if it uses
it well no something is only broken if
it's not training agents well right it's
an
approximation it's an approximation that
was like easy to make and made stuff
relatively fast um we have other ones we
have other approximations in puffer as
well and it still just
works don't want to distract you from
game balancing I'm already very
distracted but uh enjoy Game Dev yeah
it's really cool like we're basically
autobalancing this game because
reinforcement learning just learns the
new meta in 10 minutes it's pretty
fun we just figured out okay this is how
I'm going to get back on track so we
just figured out that there's this huge
level difference between different agent
classes and I think that's because you
only get XP on last hit so I should
Implement uh XP sharing um yes that's
what I should do
so what we're going to do is
is man I need to do agents in range
team five just share with the last three
attackers no they could be across the
board from you
what's a good way to do
this because I have to know how many to
share it with
first I mean this get this call this
code does not get called that
often kind of often
I can just check nearby I can just check
if you're in range there are only five
players on the team that's not hard to
to
compute B into
three is this actually valid or is this
call back to to python I guess we'll see
right
okay so we do uh 4 I in range five
valid in I don't know if it calls back
to python though like this is supposed
to run in pure C so we'll figure that if
it compiles nicely or not it
should so what we'll do
is let's
yes
team and then we have to do a distance
calc do we have a distance
function do we not use this anywhere
this L1 distance Cal
oh I just do it in
line that's fine
do in XP
range is XP range is pretty big isn't
it say five
good quite larg DOTA
yeah this is how far you can see though
by default as well so we'll put it like
this then we do in range is true
range plus equal
1 and then what we do
is we go over
equals p and then it's ali.
XP plus equals XP
not in range by
continue if
Ally
XP
then
continue and
range I mean this is kind of gross but
it's only uh 24 lines of code for XP
sharing there a better way to do
this you need to know how many allies
you're splitting with wa that's how it
works in Dota right you like you don't
all get the XP you have to split the XP
entities no avoiding that you do have to
call this annoying function twice
here it's not bad
death I
forgot I forgot I forget my cep
type
declarator wait is this real 14
runs you know guys technically if we
ported this to see we could run it on
the browser we could play we could play
DotA puffer
okay we'll see based on this if uh if
the game is less
mode oh it's just like the Vim binding I
should have guessed
okay so this will run now and we'll see
whether uh this does anything
reasonable it's 315 I'm going to take a
few minutes while this trains perfect
timing use the restroom I'm going to
make myself
uh a shake and uh then we will continue
balancing this thing for a few more
hours so that'll be good your m is
training faster than my
pong well I don't know optimize it right
it should be able to run pong at million
FPS come on let's get
going you can't get pong to run at a
million FPS how you going to do all of
doist right
I can look at a profile of it if you
want if you like if you do uh like with
annotate on or whatever if you like link
code with like um compiled with scon
with like the annotate flag I'll look at
it when I get back I'll be back in I
don't know like five seven maybe 10
minutes max be right
I realized I have a cookie here that I
forgot to
looking
um did I implement this wrong cuz all
the levels are
we'll look at the XP in a second let me
help with this first
um agent I trained with for four
minutes holy hell yo that's awesome do
you know if you're matching the Dynamics
to the original game like ball
acceleration or whatever if that's a
thing
sick you kept like the puffer s in
background as well I love
out cuz I think we're going to have to
retrain this 100% is not 100% the same
cool ball speed up in paddle getting
smaller is implemented all right awesome
I didn't know the paddle got smaller
that's funny
if you hit the top wall the paddle gets
smaller I didn't know that was a
thing wait that's like so evil cuz isn't
like the whole idea the whole strategy
to like get the ball like so it bounces
a whole bunch on the top
so yeah we didn't implement this
perfectly did we
indented ooh this this is
tough hold
bottom I don't want to make a mess with
this
code because it's like
away and then you check you check the
level here
is this
good so now you have your XP reward
based on shared XP so just like being
near an ally that is doing getting XP is
just as good so this encourages
teamwork no I'm going to do another run
of this so link your code and I'll look
at it for 10 minutes
you did okay perfect let me get this run
going
let me make sure this runs and then
we'll do a new
experiment and I'll help you fix your
code I like this puffer
MOBA it's a lot of
fun
okay
hypers did you add sound
effects if so that's actually funny as
no I don't see it yet but that's fun
that's a fun
HTML is not up to date okay uh if you
can recompile and push that that would
be a good
idea I think I put it in the get ignore
well like you have a version of it and
if you commit the latest one and I I can
like look to see if there's any yellow
or anything that needs to be fixed here
because I see a few things if it hasn't
changed like um
this reset could be cpde for
instance um this right here this could
be out this could
be uh either this could be Memory viewed
or something like that um and then you
wouldn't have to do a loop here that
calls back to
python you're probably losing quite a
bit with those
yet I I could also just start messing
with this to be
fair I might already have your stuff
installed don't I
there so yeah I still see the same thing
right here this could be Memory viewed
you're calling back to python right
here this could be CP de which would get
rid of a lot of
this though this is probably not a huge
performance
overhead how's the reset
work good you did an efficient reset
good
job
um yep that's fine
those are the two big things I see um I
could look at this math to see if
there's any way to optimize
this there might be some way to optimize
here
I mean would you like me what how do you
want me to go about this so like I can
tell you I can just try to optimize this
a bit myself or if this is like a
learning end for you I can give you like
precise instructions on how I would go
about making this thing Ultra fast would
that be useful or would you like have
you already tried a bunch and do you
want me to just like see if I can take a
crack at it real quick I'll leave that
up to
you tell me how I can improve it okay so
I don't know if you can clip this or
whatever but here
so what I would do
is do you know how to use C
profile first of all do you know how to
use C
delay no okay I'll show you so in Puffer
you should actually have it in here so
like I think I have one in the
MOBA yeah so the puffer profile mode uh
I forget if that does it for you I think
that profiles all of training which is
not what you want so here's an example
in the MOBA
code you can see right here there's like
this little per test right you should be
able to pretty much just copy this
exactly you'll notice I pre-allocate
actions so that we don't waste time on
RNG um and then you just run this little
C profile command here C profile import
run and then this is going to give you
uh a stats. profile file and then this
little piece of code yeah this will give
you your stats printed out okay so now
I'm going to tell you how to make that
useful so the first thing that you
should do is you should just uh get this
like good setting so I think you have
this vectorized internally right like
num MS
numb agents I see in there yeah so you
could just set this to like 4096 or
whatever it is that you're going to use
right you run this on your wrapper uh
your like your python wrapper you you
run like just like I have in the MOBA
and you see without uh profile mode so
keep this flag false you see how much
time you're leaking in the python
wrapper versus in the uh C code if
you're leaking stuff in the python
wrapper you look for things that need to
be done less frequently like let me
check if you're doing logging
correctly Port
interval you're doing logging correctly
because you copied the Moa I think yeah
this should be fine
correctly yes you're doing profiling
correctly so I don't see anything that
should be super slow in here though you
might be
surprised um but you start off you run C
profile you see if you're leaking time
in the python and if you're leaking like
more than 10% in the python you should
probably optimize that but then the big
thing is you're going to compile this
with profile equal true and then that
profiler is actually going to tell you
how much time is spent in each of your C
functions so initially that'll just tell
you how much time you're spending in
reset versus step for instance so you'll
be able to see if you have like a really
slow reset function or something though
this looks pretty much
fine um but then after that what you can
do is you can
you can factor out some of these pieces
of code into methods like you already
have done this with handle collisions so
I guess that will already tell you but
like if you need to go deeper into this
right you could factor out like brick
ball collisions for instance right um
and you could check that and C profile
will quickly tell you where you're going
to uh you're going to run into issues
now I just noticed the way that you're
actually doing this and I can basically
guarantee you that this is the problem
right here
um yeah it's Pro it's got to be this
right here so you're checking collisions
with all
bricks there's got to be a better way of
doing this
hope how's the actual Collision code
work for Atari I wonder
is that publicly available I don't know
maybe somebody's decompiled it by now
well the thing is there are a number of
ways you could do this Noah technically
um but you probably want to match the
Atari kind of closely so I would say
just like look at this and see how far
you can get I mean you could probably
one thing I could think of easily is
like you could check one row at a time
for
instance you're never going to be
colliding with like you're never going
to be spanning more than two
rows so you can probably prune there and
there go like 80% of those checks
right like you know if you're below the
if you're below the uh the lowest level
you don't check at all so that's 80%
pruned right there and then of the
remainder you're only ever going to have
to check like two rows at most and then
the same thing with columns so
technically you should just be able to
check like I think you only have to
check four blocks at most right two
above two below
potentially so I think that you can
probably prune like 95% of that out very
easily and then it'll run
fast but I would profile first like make
sure that this is the problem I'm pretty
sure it will be so you're probably what
you're going to do is you're going to
factor this out into like brick
collisions or whatever you're going to
run the profile you're going to see that
all the time is right in here and then
you're going to like based on that
you're going to go back and forth until
it's fast again and also notice note
that the profiler itself has a bunch of
overhead so you're looking for relative
improvements in the profiler and then
you take the profile art off once in a
while to see how well you're doing in
absolute
terms that's my advice to you
and you should be able to get this thing
to be very nice and
fast also you might want to consider
caching some of this math
um like brick W height plus brick height
ball height stuff like this you can
probably cash some of this math up top
though probably the thing that I
suggested will have way more of an
impact than that
I'm surprised that this double slash
works and doesn't call back to C I
didn't think that was a thing oh maybe
it's the C division flag
okay but yeah I think that with what
I've shown with what I've told you you
should probably be able to break a
million pretty easily let me see if
there's anything else Drank in here
good I think this is the only thing
that's
Jank I mean there might be some logic
that you can cash
right like there might be some math you
can cash but other than that you're
probably good all right there's your
feedback for the time being
see let's see what
happened let's see what
yeah this is more aligned with what I
expected
so there's still a level difference a
big level difference but not as crazy as
before burst and carry are
overpowered or the other ones are
underpowered we'll look at that
sure I think I take a couple quick
seconds take a few more sips of the
shake and then I'm going to lock in for
a little bit of balance on
this did anybody give a damn about the
snake environment let's
it did okay I'd expect this type of
thing for to make uh get more people
interested but you know it's a
relatively simple and it's not as cool
looking as like the mobile would
be still
though the nice thing is I'll be able to
use this one for a long time cuz it's
like you just go to the dock site and
you just you he snake
right this runs on phones too it's that
this I guess I'll just tab back and
forth right
okay so let's take a quick look now at
the
skills
um we basically have this guy just
bullying bullying everybody
right we've
got burst and carry very very strong
we also haven't added stat scaling at
all have
we we did like a really vague damage
scaling
thing I think we didn't add like class
specific scaling or spell
scaling we'll see if we have to do
that I would think we will have to do
that right because otherwise like the
Spells are
just spells have to get substantially
better
actually the Assassin and the tank look
balanced
right they're half a level over the
support which is about what we want
maybe a level or two
has what is making the carry so
good let's see if we can go understand
that
um move my camera
so it's sure not their
Q it's their W and E that are apparently
good so they have
a they have a decent
AOE and then they have a slow this
really doesn't look that
overpowered this actually looks very
weak so either it's bugged or I'm not
seeing something
AOE
and a 100 damage like 100 damage attack
slow
somehow how the heck is the Assassin not
way
better I guess the Assassin is just not
better because it's spamming the um it's
using all its mana on moving it actually
has a very strong skill that it's just
not
using
okay what about the
tank why is the tank not this good
it's really weird to me how the tank
has no higher damage
received than anything else but it has
that much healing does that even make
sense
the tank should have like way higher
damage received shouldn't
oh I think it's because I'm counting
overhealing I'm counting over I need to
not count overhealing
see no I didn't because target. Health
has to be up here
on this is one of our Pokemon
devs who's currently sorely without
Hardware because of Intel
issues what's the cleanest way of doing
this
all right not sure what's up with bet
today but
welcome it's uh I guess it might
actually be like like 600 p.m. or
whatever for you 5:00 p.m.
somewhere um [ __ ] how do I do this
easily just got
welcome we are using RL to help Auto
balance this game
I'll help you fix RL real quick give me
a
sec if by a sec you mean a quick decade
then maybe
right now let's just do
this that's that's easy enough
health Target health is greater than
this then
okay so this should hopefully fix
it yeah I did I rebuilt
UI and hopefully we actually will
see more reason able damage received
numbers and such I don't know if we will
actually see anything different we'll
see I would assume then it's just like
the tank is spamming its heal ability
and not actually healing itself very
efficiently or something weird like
that is why we saw those numbers be so
inflated
I missed a post what what did
youan I missed something important
didn't
healing
dealt
okay damage
received
tank it's receiving almost as much as
the Assassin which I guess is just like
suicide
charging shower and what are you doing
man
homeowner yeah you're also married
shower and sing that's like some serious
Bachelor
support okay this is actually this fixed
the stats I think yeah this fixed the
stats it's no longer tracking like
Overkill and overheal so now we're
actually getting reasonable
numbers this is
good are you just YOLO balancing this
so what's going on here is we have a
really really good set of
hyperparameters from carbs uh at least
for the UN like before we messed with it
right but they're probably still pretty
good for this so what I'm doing is I
have all these stats saying how often
all the different classes are using
their various skills I have stats that
are telling me how much damage they're
doing what their levels are and
everything so I can basically see what
skills are broken what skills are
overpowered uh I can see what classes
are currently overtuned or like
undertuned and I can just like make some
small
changes
and I can rerun the training and then we
can see if they learn a new meta meaning
that like I fix the skills or if the
skills still suck meaning that either
you know they're not learning it or more
likely the skills are just
bad so it's pretty cool because like you
can make changes and get and have like
them develop their new meta in 10
minutes 10 15 minutes there's a 250 mil
step experiment right
nice you're training at SPS is above I
think it's like 350 or something
yeah 350 it's uh it's slower than it
should be because the hyper parameters
it found have like four update Epoch or
something normally it can train at like
600 but hey according to uh carbs this
is the fastest wall clock uh for
performance setting after doing over 500
experiments
it's pretty cool the uh the sweeps let
me
see is this it
yeah so this sweep
here ELO over
time 500
experiments you can see the
Improvement all the way up to 2400 ELO
starting from I think they get
initialized to a
th000 so if like a th000 is
random very nice ELO
curve very nice ELO
curve these are reasonably at least like
doing a 100 experiment sweep is
reasonably quick as
well most of the testing I disable the
RNN also have sweet pram look
good happens to be apparent I mean it's
when correlation it's like that's carbs
doing it job right it's like the longer
you run carbs the better it should get
at discovering you know it should be
more accurate at estimating what hyper
prams are good and should be launching
better
experiments if you mess stuff up yeah I
mean there there's stuff that couldn't
go wrong but it's getting pretty stable
these
days you just need like an initial set
of hyper prams that learns at least
something reasonable
so this is done in five minutes let me
see if I can tell anything so far
um healing
dealt so the support
is is using its AOE heal a bunch but
it's like the primary beneficiary of its
own
heal so it's kind of not great I guess
it's the support is kind of tanking
isn't
it but it's not tanking that much damage
really
received shouldn't these guys have like
way more damage dealt than received
damage dealt
carry damage received oh yeah okay so
the carry is taking all the minion kills
I guess the burst in the carry are
taking all the minion kills so that's
why they have the higher damage Dean
received old tar naturally best action
is to spam heel yeah you just Spam heel
off cool
down how are the levels now with this
these changes um yeah burst and carry
are like super overtuned or the other
three are way
undertuned I actually don't think that
the Assassin is necessarily undertuned
it has a very good kit it's just not
learning to use it the tank and the
support
though it's really weird how okay I can
see the burst the burst character is
just super broken
right it's got some really good
skills are there creeps to last hit in
Gold um there are
creeps
there is not there 's no gold there are
creeps and the creeps give
XP it's the same as it's you can look at
it basically the same as League though
there's some additional
stuff they're minion waves they are
neutrals their
camps there are skills there are hero
classes
all those normal
things we're going to have to start
making some decisions here
depends on how you want to balance
y so let's see support
has it has a hook ability that says it
says it
likes it has a heal ability that's quite
well
balanced and it has a stun ability that
I think should be really good but it
doesn't seem to
like bot Lane met as ADC gets all last
hit creeps yeah I know I've played
League that doesn't really exist because
there's no gold it's just
XP but there should still be plenty of
room for play around like the waves and
stuff you don't get XP if they just die
you actually you some somebody has to
last hit them for you to get XP so it's
a little different XP level up Stronger
Yeah we don't have scaling for spells
yet but we do have scaling for your
health in your damage so you do get
substantially stronger from levels
this is just like an incredibly strong
skill I
guess the fact is that you can do this
with one Mana bar I think is the
combo giving to a different class take
it away
yeah well I can see right here right I
can see exactly what skills it's using
look if I just look here I see this is
the burst class right uh I can see it
has q w and E it's using all the skills
but it's favoring its q and its
e which
is Q oh is that
so wait q w e is the stun so it likes
this stun it's actually it's using all
these things in a very balanced way it's
it's just that like I think it's just
overtuned is all I think it needs higher
Mana
costs see if that class gets similar
results
here being able to do this in one Mana
bar is pretty broken
the thing is I don't even think that's
what it
400 nice to visualize this too
how I mean I have the graphs but they
don't tell you anything more than this
does got a follow yeah there no
animations yet though so basically what
you see is you see them like just
massacring everything and getting tons
of
levels it's fun to play though see you
tablin thanks for dropping by
don't forget to start the
puffer helps us out a
I mean I think I'm overthinking this
right it's got to just be that the the
ability it's using the most is really
really strong
include I mean it can at level one it
can one shot it can basically oneshot an
enemy hero with
this so I think that this thing needs we
really need to implement
scaling it's only 4:20
p.m. I have some hours
here I'm trying to think if I just want
to like bite the bullet and Implement
skill scaling now so that I don't have
to rebalance after that because like
right now it's really hard to balance
because 500 damage is completely
reasonable um it's just not reasonable
at level one it's reasonable at like
level
five balance for base I can't balance
for the base though
you can't balance for the base because
like well okay actually no that doesn't
make sense though bet because if I
balance for base you're not going to be
able to tell looking at this because if
the scaling is different right they're
playing full games
balance is very tricky in general but
it's substantially easier for
RL because basically like game devs they
have to put out they have to announce
their game and like put out a beta and
do play testing and stuff whereas we can
just run the RL agents for 15 minutes
and we can see what the new meta is
right that's a huge
Advantage I'm actually incredibly amazed
how well this
works I think that we have
to I think we should like start on uh on
the scaling here because we have hyper
prams that we know are reasonable at
least so if it just stops working we'll
know we'll have broken something there
where it has the least damage dealt
doesn't it it literally has the least
damage
dealt of everything
undertuned and they still have Auto
attacks like that includes just Auto
attacks on random minions and
balancing it'll be relatively chill and
easy just take a little bit of time I'm
feeling pretty good here we can just
start
level what general scheme do you have to
test for team comp balance there's no
team comp it's a mirror match 5v5 they
five classes mirror
match same every time we're not doing
we're not doing hero
pools yeah it's a mirror it's a 5v5
mirror
match if anybody wants to [ __ ] about
that they can go kod MOBA but like I
don't want to have to
balance I don't want to have to balance
like hero selection and stuff or like
make the agent select its team or
something well it's inherently balanced
with like one side to the other but it's
like individual classes should still be
balanced right what they're
contributing maybe it doesn't out well
we'll
see humans aren't playing
it what program is it this is puffer
mooba this is hold on let's see if we
have it in a playable state
we can play this for a second play with
the RL agents real
quick where's the
command looks like it runs hold
on there we go we can play the puffer
mooba and we have reinforcement learned
teammates and reinforcement learned
opponents
let GPT 4 balance it I don't think I
want to ever let gp4 touch my code ever
again to be
honest I don't think I want to let
Claude touch my code ever again
either I think I'm pretty I'm in a
pretty happy State just like w in my my
own code you
know honestly like all the people saying
oh Claude just lets you do anything it's
just skill issue now learn to freaking
code if you can't write your own code
then like and you think that your value
is going to be impr prompting claw like
you just have no
value hard tech skills are
always the best thing you can invest
in don't use them then just like you
learned a code right
hard tech skills are always the most
valuable
thing my actual favorite take is like
the mbas who think that uh oh look cuz
like Claude is going to automate coding
now like NBAs are the one with the real
value it's like no they're going to make
you worthless
first coding is actually hard to do
right
it's their selling point there yeah I
see this a lot and it's just
like been just slown I know how you guys
operate you're morons most of you at
least there's absolutely no value like
what you think that like oh yeah I just
I came up with an idea that nobody else
is bothered to type into Claud no that's
not how it works the hard part is always
execution and building stuff
yeah well it's tough when you don't have
any way to like you have literally no
objective way to measure your skills
right like in programming I can
immediately tell if somebody's good it's
you just you link your GitHub and I'll
look at your code and I'll say okay this
person knows what they're doing this
person doesn't know what they're doing
right not really any way to do that with
soft
skills especially not with like people
skills
because I mean even let's say you have
like you know soft like let's say that
you're a really good writer I can read
your stuff and say okay this is very
good writing
right
but I don't know it's always important
to have those measures
I'm getting distracted in philosophical
now getting philosophical is
stupid no need to be
philosophical need to build
stuff
um
damage attack cool down
attack
damage but the philosophers were
yeahp on kill I think the way we are
going to do
this is what we're we're going to have
to
right I like the idea of keeping Max
Mana at
100 do
I yeah cuz Mana in this game it refills
rather
quickly so we can just make your spells
like
Works let's look up the DOTA stats I
want to look up a couple characters
unlike DOTA
buff the DOTA website does not have good
stats
I guess this short of sort of shows you
though like over the course of the game
85 up to 325
damage stun duration goes
up right move speed
bonus 500 up to 900 and this starts at
this was my favorite character to play
in the brief amount of time that I
played DOTA which was fun
she has a lot of Mana for uh she has a
lot of Mana doesn't she as well
like what does like
um trying to think like what is
uh what do you
have you much lower Mana right
details I think we started a base of
like 500
250 something like
that why not create a 1 V
one version and use ELO to
C calibrate hero
um well like if you think about
that does that make sense
because if it's a mirror match versus
you know just like your own other class
it's not really going to tell you very
much other than which abilities you're
using and which you aren't which we
already have here
um yeah it's it's a little
tricky I think I think we're like I'm
overthinking this though I think I'm
just like nerd sniping myself getting
like too into the details here I think
that all I have to do
is I put like
this yeah cuz I'm not balancing team
like you have 300 Mana
here let me think so the
support support should have uh what a
decent bit of
Mana burst has
Mana okay so the support starts off
average
stats assassin starts
off uh lower health I think
50 well we'll let let's just paste all
the things and we'll
decide radiant burst definitely starts
off
with lower
Health should probably make it like more
no well
maybe cuz there's no armor in this at
the moment so I have to like I have to
compensate with health and health
scaling so let's see so like the tank
has got to have like 700 Health
right and then the squishiest one should
have like 300 health right which is is
mid squishy or carry squishy
here I think mid is no it's got to be
carrye as the easy one to dive right I
think mid starts off
like
normal Carri starts
off
yeah and Carrie doesn't
get yeah very
squishy doesn't get a ton of Mana for
spells just gets really good scaling
damage mids range
yep so tank is going to
get 200 Mana
okay what I'm trying to think which
class I use to calibrate around I guess
it's like mid no which is like the
normal I guess it's support
right support is like the balanced
[Music]
whatever they magic and F no they're
just damage dude
okay and then how much is it going to
gain per level
lot let me see if I can get a range
here like Earth Shaker's tanky
right so what does he get he gets 3100
HP by level 30 compared to what's Lena
get I mean but then the thing is there's
armor I'm not accounting for
uh 2200 okay so there's like a range of
like thsh HP
okay 50 and then damage
per level
is
10 six times Ally level is what I
decided on here
low damage gain per
level and do it greetings from Venom
vuela
hello I think this is a good base set of
stats
right damage gain per level should
be hold on the base damage if I do 10 is
going to
be it's like 3500 well that's hold on
350 base attack damage seems like a
lot no actually that's about right
because you have like 2 3K attack so I
think this is about right
actually okay so we have Max Mana
health and then player HP gain per
level I think that the Assassin
is Rel atively
gets
60 there's so many numbers I'm just
guessing but I think it's fine I mean we
can we'll
balance damage gain per level
yeah squishy and play style yeah so
that's what I was going for here he's
pretty
squishy has a little bit of bulk but not
a
ton radiant burst here
um burst should
be HP gain per
level probably about the same as
assassin it gets one step down maybe
this is how we'll think about it is
we'll do like it in
steps scale aggressively yeah so that's
I'm going to give it I'm going to give
it like very good uh scaling on its it
spells basically
lane a spell character let me see so HP
G per level I think one step down is
appropriate uh we're going to do two
steps up
whoops two steps up it gains 80 Mana per
level that seems lame
though I think we want to step
by by 15s so this will be a
65 and then this will be 90 Mana per
level
yeah and then damage gain per level is
not going to be anything
special like this is a mage it should be
pretty
low scale it
yep Mana will be good
has uh tank is going to
get I like 150 HP gain per
level Mana gain per level is going to be
way lower
20 damage gain per
level not 20 I think 15 is
carry HP gain per level is the
squishiest Mana gain per level
is I'd say average right and then
damage gain per level is
25 I don't know if this is going to make
sense because like this is going to
create a ridiculous difference actually
now that I'm looking at it cuz you'll
only get you'll get 1500 HP here and the
tank will get
actually I'm thinking like if I'm
screwing stuff up for my observations as
yeah I think I just got to not overthink
too much um here we'll do
player this is base
Health base Health base Mana
base Health based Mana
everybody we can do same base damage for
everybody
now we have to do the the
um the scaling for spells which is going
to be substantially
harder uh we also need to keep in mind
the the new base value so we
now we are still designing for 500 base
Health on
average um but now Mana is 250 on
average and more for spellcasters
okay so skill support
hook um
do we want to increase Mana cost over
time it's kind of weird that DOTA like
gives you more mana and then it
also increases the cost doesn't isn't
that
weird how much does the cost go
up the cost doesn't go up a
ton I could simply have the Mana scale
less aggressively and not do that right
maybe I'm just scaling the Mana to
aggressiv
ller anything I'm scaling
Mana too aggressively
maybe if you have 1500 Mana you're
always going to have freaking Mana
aren't
plus this is
good AOE heal this one is already very
level so level 30 this is
800 is good I think this is
good for an AOE heal this is nice and
strong I
think 200 at level
one is I think reasonable
maybe
25 it's already a very strong
800 I think it needs to be
25 I'm just guessing here basically is
all I'm doing oh and then the Mana cost
has got to be way higher for sure this
is a 150 Mana
spell and then the welcome back bet and
then the timer on this
that is a 12 second timer that feels
plus player.
Level D this is a 12 second stun that's
[ __ ] no that's like insane this has
got to be like a 3 second stun
right yeah 12 isn't I think I did this
like because they they weren't used it
but I think we got to go way back down
to 15 it's five per tick
way there it can get up to a sixc stun
at max level that's still [ __ ] broken
actually like the
amount push amount
uh we don't need these variables I think
it's we can just do it in
and it has a very weak amount of
damage associated with
it I think this damage is too
weak
maybe
plus 10 times player do level
only if I do that it's not going to make
any sense because there's like scaling
versus no scaling
I man it's really like that not that's
not going to tell me anything other than
like if you run with scaling versus no
scaling the team that doesn't scale gets
merked how much damage have I allowed
for here
250 40 time player.
level I think this has got to
be 200 let's try
this uh this has to be expensive
you can't just be spamming this
[ __ ] oh well I yeah I can't just be
changing one thing at a time though it's
fine I have sufficient logging in
metrics that I can change a bunch of
[ __ ] at the time and it probably will
just be
fine first AOE this is going to be a 150
fine um I can't really test if they're
good automatically bet I can just test
if they're balanced so the idea is going
to be that I balance this I add some
more in and [ __ ] I play all the
characters and I see if they actually
make any sense when I'm like playing
against the
opponents and then we'll like tweak
finer from there but like this is just
the initial
pass this is an
AOE stun which should also be
expensive it's [ __ ] crazy 8C stun am
I insane 8C AOE
seconds on an 8sec cool down you have
that no
way I letting each her well to test it
you got to play your own
game same it's true in reinforcement
learn it's true everywhere else
right I kind of like this ability this
one's kind of cool because it's like
it's
channeled I think it's got to be 20
though or tick
how long do I want to be able to hold
this button down you can hold this down
for a long time
right channeling is not complex at all
it's literally just something where if
you hold the button down you can keep
using the skill it's just a skill that
doesn't have a cool
down the way I have it implemented
here yeah it turns out that like if you
don't want to do everything perfectly
one to one I mean it is a channeled
skill right you hold the button down and
it keeps
going oh no not really not like casting
time
no I mean it wouldn't be that hard to do
that either if I really wanted
to let's see I do
[Music]
20 this is 100 DP s for 100 Mana is that
gets what do you guys get you
get
200 for 200 Mana but it scales pretty
aggressively as an AOE this is kind of
overpowered
yeah know this is completely [ __ ]
overpowered at 10 damage it's
okay and then what you you increase this
and then it becomes
40 becomes 200
DPS I think that's still freaking broken
dude
need to have a
chart I mean it's not that hard to think
about right
like you don't have to think about it
that way though bet like you literally
just like you just throw some [ __ ] at
the wall and then like you see what
agents use and if they use it it's good
and if they don't use it it's bad it's
that
simple okay I know how to I know how to
explain this imagine that you were a
game Dev that had a million players like
playing your game 24/7 that were really
good at figuring out new metas like very
quickly and they never get mad because
you ship
garbage right that's basically what it
is it's like you can just push random
[ __ ] and like if it's not working
they'll just tell you instantly and then
you can just like oh okay okay tweak
that and whatever
right it's that easy
okay self heal 250 self heal is very
strong but supposed to be very strong
okay so it has a nice cool down on it's
not crazy expensive very good
skill and then this engage
AOE can be
good do you know any commercial uses of
RL ml game balancing Riot tried to do it
for a
while I pitched them on puffer as well
they were doing stuff with any skill uh
with uh Ray which is why they were very
big
sad because RB is very hard to make do
things I actually can't think of
uh different
rayb RL not rayb my bad RB's awesome ray
is also awesome rib is bad yeah r i RB
is awesome uh is pretty good rlb is
bad I actually can't think of like a
thing that I'd like I would not I can't
think anything of anything that sounds
worse to work on but like trying to do
RL in like a Big Fang engineering way
that sounds like God
awful I bet you I can solve a lot of
Industry problems with like the type of
stuff I do but I don't think there's
like any way to make any progress when
you try to like oh we have to Enterprise
ready
everything it's not going to
work carry Retreat
slow okay so you can't charge too much
for
this cuz they don't have a [ __ ] ton of
Mana I think
50 plus it's 150 Mana for
I don't think they like this skill
anyway so we're going to make it cheap R
tried to do it it didn't work I I don't
know what the status of their stuff is
to be honest uh they got some things to
kind of work like they were they were
doing good stuff it's just like it was
incredibly painful to see what they had
to go through to make anything work
because it was just like freaking
software it's just hard
good they weren't sold on I think they
just already had their thing going with
uh with any scale I could have done a
lot of stuff for
them I could have definitely done a lot
of stuff for
them yeah
well I mean it's kind of a hard sell if
you think about it cuz
like there's just there's really no
other solution when you have like such a
big pile of infrastructure it's like you
can't you're going to have to do some
stuff simpler for a while and you're
going to have to do it
right I don't know I came up with some
pretty good ideas for them one of the
things that I pitched them on that I
think would be really awesome so you've
played league right
bet I was going to do um I was going to
you know how there's like there's uh the
camera control options where like you
can have locked Cam that new players use
but then like you're supposed to get uh
you're supposed to play unlocked but
it's like a pain in the ass for new
players to learn how to play unlocked
and it's really just not fun CU it just
feels super
clunky right you know how it feels just
super clunky funy learning that and it's
like annoying as hell for new players
cuz like you have to learn camera
control as a mechanic and like yeah
obviously Pros are going to want to do
it but like if you're some random silver
or gold it's like you're kind of just
mad about
it yeah so I pitched them hey why don't
you add an RL camera control
option why don't we just like let's not
like go do anything crazy to the whole
game let's just add a reinforcement
learned camera control option that like
does some imitation learning and makes
the camera work like pros so that like
all your new players don't get turned
off by by having to do
this right I figured that was like a
cool way to add something to a game with
RL well like you know respecting the the
long history of league and not like you
know trying to do RL creeps or something
like that I figured that was like the
type of thing that these industry should
do to like get their foot in the door
with a
tech yeah
a ram and unranked
right and then if it looks good you uh
you ship it I figured that would be like
a cool thing that we could do with
them I was just going to do like some
imitation learning thing like that would
be pretty basic and um and then what I
would do is like I'd ship that as a
quick demo cuz that wouldn't take that
long to figure out how to do and then
like come up with some like reward like
some smoothness reward or something and
then like try to tune it with RL that
was kind of the plan they didn't go for
it
though no I gave him a really good pitch
as well this was a while back though
this was before puffer was anywhere near
as mature as it is now
um yeah I gave a really really good
pitch as well but I think they already
had you know their own internal stuff
going
on they didn't say that they didn't say
any specific issues they just like kind
of like thanked me for the thing and
then they like just told me like hey you
know yeah we're not going to go for
this I pitched them a few other things
as well of that sort of
quality and I kind of went I went
through I actually you want to know how
much work I'd put into that um I
actually don't really play competitive
games right i' like I've been like an
MMO junkie I went and I got ranked from
scratch in every single one of their
games so I did like all the trial
matches right you know how long that
takes got ranked in
valerant got ranked in League got ranked
in legends of Runa even got L ranked in
team fight tactics
their games are all
good I think team TFT was not for me but
valerant was freaking awesome I ended up
loving that League was like tilting as
hell and if I weren't stressed from
everything else it would probably be
good but you know it was it was still
fun times for a bit um it's like a game
I don't have enough time to invest into
right and then even Runa was like i'
never played a card game and I was
enjoying
games I don't know maybe in the future
down the
line MMO in the works I don't have any
private knowledge man I thought I saw
something in the news articles that they
weren't doing it that they shelved it
but I don't know see that's like the
type of thing where I could have really
done something
cool I could have really done something
cool with that H
ho right
so I don't know what that is I got no
private knowledge
that's one of the reasons I opened up
puffer to be more than just like for
games um even though I thought games
would be a really good initial
application is because like it was
really hard to work with game
companies unique movements only
possible huh
I don't
know I mean honestly like I'm not too
bothered like I think that's what's
going to usually happen with a lot of
these like with a lot of the places that
are doing RL even the ones that are
investing pretty heavily like if they're
not being led by like I honestly I think
RL is one of those things where there
may be a hundred people in the world who
are actually qualified to lead any
substantial RL projects and if you don't
have one of them you're just going to
fail so
like I'm perfectly happy to just like
for the time being you know I'm going to
let people who I'm going to I'll put
puffer out there and you know if you
want to work with puffer that's awesome
and if you don't that's fine you know
you can come back when and if it makes
sense for you because I'm pretty darn
confident that it's going to be very
very difficult to just inhouse ourl
stuff right I wouldn't be working in
this space if it were easy right if it
were easy I'd let somebody else do it
companies well I'm not I'm not going to
be the thing is I intend to spend most
of my time building stuff right I'm not
going to go around pitching companies
that are like doing language models hey
you shouldn't be doing language models
you should be doing RL like there are
enough places that know what RL is and
like want to use it for stuff it has a
totally different performance profile
from llm it was fine I don't have to I
don't need the whole
Market but I do have to start working on
the business side of puffer a little bit
just so that we can start funding some
stuff and scaling up compute
I have a few more things to try as well
I know I have some
plants carry
AOE uh this is kind of gross isn't
it why do they have
this this is
like two WR
damage oh cuz I didn't give it
scaling but they're not supposed to have
crazy scaling
right yeah their skills are mostly
rily crowd balance
too kind
of I have to like I would need
animations and stuff because it's pretty
hard to play right now like I can play
it cuz I know what all the code does
like I can kind of play it but it will
be easier once I add some like basic
attack animations or at least some
visual disting
distinction I'll work on the animations
after a
bit I don't want to do that just
yet
okay 100 Mana
times we just do this initially we still
have a few rounds of balancing that we
can do
today assassinate TP this is really
freaking good so this is going to
be yeah
three this is like its main freaking
ability
this 150
Mana it's very
strong and then the move buff is going
to
be
channed 20 Mana
it's 100 Mana per
second that's kind of a
lot I'll leave it like this it's going
to be overpowered as [ __ ] for now
int and ton stun
[Music]
timer
1159 1195
does this work or do I have to do
this I don't
know we'll do that to be
safe I don't know what scon
double to int
really maybe I did this wrong
here it's a puppet
box let's see if this runs
okay we'll see if it actually learns
anything whatsoever
okay well it's not completely
failing
right somehow we made the burst and
carry even more overpowered which is
about
right we should also probably log hero
kills what you mean no they're freaking
level 24 and 26 compared to
12 carry one got
fed fed by what they're running down
mid they're just running it down
mid
damage yeah the reason that they have
59k damage is because they're overtuned
as
hell 13k
is the support doing
anything the support is not doing
anything
right what do you mean look at the other
side damage
dealt yeah the Assassin and the tank
aren't doing anything
[Music]
right you realize like it's it's damage
Delton received there's no
it's not showing you per
team this is 200 games at no this is way
more than 200 games running in parallel
I am confused what do you want about
group the damn
stats this is
honorous well we can fix a few things
it's actually kind of obnoxious to group
the stats
though
um like
I have to inter leave the freaking
things I guess I can do
it I mean I could also just make it so
that puffer lib writes down and then
writes you know on the next
side I could just do a puffer update in
the relatively near future for that
instead of having to mess up all this
nice code because otherwise I have to
inter leave
them rapper no no rapper dude that's
[ __ ] we just it's like five lines of
code change and clean puff ra all that I
just don't want to think about right
now I can just change five lines of code
and clean puff orl it just has to write
the stats it just calculates the total
number and then it routes down instead
of writing columnwise it's
easy no
rappers rappers for the week
so the support has caught up hasn't it
hold on the support caught
interesting did the support learn to get
good
what I mean we have a lot to balance
with this right
so unless I broke something
but damage dealt by
support the healing from the support is
really
low that's the one thing I'm confused
with the healing needs to be higher
a let's go look at some stuff here
anything on the
twitters anything blowing up I should be
aware
you like your sake stuff probably with
Mondays Monday is usually a good day to
post I mean it's just it's the nice
thing is it's like a it's a it's a
permanent demo cuz like now it's just at
the top of the website and forever you
just have like this thing literally runs
on mobile you can't control the yellow
snake on mobile but you can watch it and
it's like the neuron Nets will literally
run on your
a little bit of a break might be a good
idea
tonight I've been preventing myself from
downloading Boulders Gate 3 so that
perer can continue to succeed and I will
play some like random things here and
there just like chill
out yeah exactly don't do that is a bad
idea bad idea
I mean I basically don't have anything
that I can do for the next like week or
so I tried to run this morning and it
was turns out 50k takes longer than a
week to recover from uh who would have
thought cuz I felt
awful it was actually freaking
terrible okay so this is done let's see
what we can rebalance from here
here coding more and gaming
less well I've done a lot of gaming I've
done a lot of coding
50k 50k hours would be a lot of
hours oh no the 50K yeah
miles how aren't you recovered well I
tried to run like I tried to run like a
lap around the dish today and I got to
the dish and I was like basically about
to like throw up and pass
out um and then I went to like so I just
ran a
5K and then I went to bench and like
everything was super shaky I still bench
240 but that's still 20 lbs down from
Max which is like a huge drop I mean 40
should be easy for
reps heck even 225 was
shaky just disgusting takes time to
recover apparently apparently a lot of
people after they run a 50k they
literally won't run for a full two weeks
and then they still taper after
that I don't know I thought I'd be good
in a
week after my first marathon I just like
I got up and I ran the next day
so dude I'm at sea level there's no
elevation heat yes
okay okay yeah but like 500 ft of
elevation does not matter for like the
the atmosphere is the same
Q so it's just using its W it's q and
not it's e
well yeah that that's not the elevation
oh I I see what you mean
yes the elevation I was I read that as
altitude for some
brutal
um it is crazy to me that they do not
use this stun
do I make this
cheaper I mean I guess I make it cheaper
for now
right and this is a pretty damn good
stun 3 second
stun we'll buff it a little
bit and
then what else
assassin basically just using its
E I think the Assassin would be
good if it just stopped doing
that as much as I hate to do this I'm
gonna make this not be channeled for now
uh I'm going to make this take 100
mana and then move timer is going to be
100 e
timer is going to
buff yeah I got to just Nerf this thing
I
think and then maybe it'll
learn assin and what about
I don't know I'd like to be able to code
on this stuff 247 bet but like I did
probably a good 25 hours of work between
Saturday and Sunday on uh the snake
thing and then on the video and it's
been you know it's a lot
AOE yeah like I could work on the video
more tonight but just like the thought
of having to do that's kind of just
disgusting at this
point so do a little more code today
maybe I'll start on that tomorrow we'll
see or like continue on that we'll see
um player AOE
[Music]
attack yeah it's like six
okay AOE attack
is it's
Q what's the tank
use he used it q and it's w and not its
e
AOA I guess that makes sense it's more
of like a high level
skill we'll bump it down we'll Nerf it
to or we'll we'll buff it to 50 Mana for
now so it's
cheap and then other than that I think
the tank's in a decent
carry these are actually reasonable
numbers honestly I think we just tweak
them a little
bit so
yeah because the skills are a little bit
imbalanced at the moment I
think this skill cost freaking 200 mana
and they still
like it a
lot I think I'm going to just Nerf it by
a little
bit to 150
maybe just makes it a little harder for
them to run away with the game early
on uh they
AOE C first W is fine
burst e they're not
using which I find really
weird
75 maybe it's 75 they'll use
it we'll
see other than that
um 14 seconds is already very long cool
down for this I think it's good
let's look at the
carry so the carry should not be super
skill dependent I mean um Carry
shouldn't be skill defendent
um it's using it's Q not at all the only
skill it's really using is it's
w CU I guess it's the only one that
does 20 times
level it's like this slow on it I guess
so we'll Nerf the
carries
main thing a little bit
and maybe that encourages it it doesn't
you like it's Q at all that's fine it's
a tech skill it's already
cheap it should like its E I think it'll
start using its e just based on
I'm kind of good to just keep deving
this for a bit I
guess we're making reasonable progress
I'd
say relatively reasonable
progress we'll be able to launch another
sweep on this plus probably an Atari
what exactly does the Assassin
do oh uh it doubles your move
healing might need a buff yeah it's
weird because on paper it should be very
strong
there's a range so healer has to be
within I could buff the heal range I
guess that would be a thing that I could
do
let's
dude I think it heals minions doesn't it
let me see
does yeah you can literally you can heal
creeps neutrals and
Towers I don't know you can [ __ ] heal
your wave it's a great pushing buff
sweet you can literally just get your
whole wave to
push that sounds really strong to me
that sounds like one of the places the
support could actually be useful
right if your carry is dead then it's
not good yeah but you can heal them all
at the same time
you can just freaking like drop this in
the middle of a half dead wave and a
half dead
carry and then you can drop a stun on
the enemy on the enemy support and like
leave let the wave killed
good yeah I don't know why it's really
low we'll see let me
see healing
dealt it's bigger than the Tank's
number I'm kind of confused by these
damage numbers like why they're
so let me see if I'm calculating healing
right
good carry Q is a tech skill I wouldn't
be surprised if they can't learn how to
do it it's um it's a defensive skill so
the carry can stay alive it pushes you
away from the enemy and it slows the
enemy I believe
so I'm not surprised that the like Rush
down mid Strat yeah it's a defensive
skill it's like uh you play league it's
kind of like I don't know like Caitlyn's
does Caitlyn's net jump you back yeah
it's like the jump back
effect I'm not surprised that they
didn't learn to use that yet
non Zerg tactics yeah well the thing is
right now just for the sake of it like I
there's a reward that's go to the enemy
ancient that seems to be very
effective um that'll like as these
things get smarter and the game actually
gets tuned properly we'll be able to do
bigger runs that like can potentially
result in more
reward there is a death
reward it's negative
well yeah like they objective bonuses
right you get um you get bonuses for
taking
Towers you get very actually you get a
very large reward for taking
Towers let's see which of these skills
are currently screwy
AOE you don't lose XP for dying in to
do no you just lose um Tempo and
stuff we are not going to optimize based
on bad we're not going to change the
game based on the neural Nets being
bad we're going to make the game
balanced and then we're going to make
the neuronet good
I think that maybe we can bump this up
to 5
AOE 250 is already a very strong
heal but here you know what we'll bump
it to 350 why
not if I make it Global it'll be
incredibly
like I guess this I guess the all need
to be buffed right cuz they're not using
the other
skills I don't know how I can make this
any stronger though
like I can make it
75 Mana
oops I can make it 75
Mana I can make it do
a bit more
damage and I can make it a it's already
a long enough stun I'll just add a
little scaling to
it it's not useful for heal because it
doesn't matter if they die it does
though
they're not taking objectives they're
not getting XP they're not getting
they're losing out on a ton of sources
of
reward yeah obviously they're like
currently stuck in the strategy of just
like run it down mid
but I mean have you seen it's actually
it's pretty it's a pretty effective
strategy at the moment like the game
needs to be balanced better so that it's
not as ridiculously effective as it is
I probably need to implement back door
protection on the towers or whatever so
that it's like you can't just skip
Towers I don't think they are skipping
Towers though as much as it's just like
they're running by each other and just
like attacking each other's
Towers no man I mean look like actual RL
DOTA was the most impressive RL project
ever done it was done by a ridiculous
crack team of like 20 um or whatever it
was and they were all freaking top of
the like they were all topnotch like
it's going to take a while before we
have Bots that do anything like super
interesting they're already doing
something right like clearly they're
already learning to use their various
abilities they're already like kind of
figuring out when abilities are good or
not and this is 50,000 parameter model
it's tiny it's still doing
something okay so we changed the support
abilities a little
bit
um changed did we change anything
tank tank should be able to get a little
bit
more
value
250 I think this should be like
350 and maybe it needs a little bit more
on its
looks like dire is pretty good I'm
pretty sure that's because
um I think it's loading the base model
though like a random model versus dire
so I'm pretty sure that's
fine so I think it's just it beats a
random policy which yeah you'd expect it
too
they're not different it's a mirror
match during training
during evaluation and the thing is it's
not built for one training run it's
built for a carb
sweep you get evaluated against all the
previous
runs or at least a random sample of
them so that's how that
works it's pretty cool for
on these levels look
good these levels look good the mid and
the carry rolls are about a level
ahead I'm actually going to pay more
attention this time to see exactly how
this
progresses of course I could just read
the graphs but this is fine too
okay now it's getting a little bit
ridiculous being a level and a half
ahead by level
six and now the carry is starting to
just
snowball three levels ahead of support
at eight is nuts
it's either the carry is too good or the
support is not good
enough but like the tank and assassin
rolls are
also about the same I think that we just
need to do like a base stat Nerf maybe
cuz the abilities seem reasonable now
maybe they just have too many base stats
Cap the thing is the burst character is
also ahead and the burst character has
like really average Auto
damage maybe burst character has to have
below average Auto
damage that would make sense right
so 10 it already has the lowest freaking
damage gain doesn't
it yeah this thing already has low
damage
it and then off the
carry what do we take we
take
five
damage and maybe we Nerf it spells a
little
bit maybe the carry spells just don't
scale super well
huh like
maybe maybe it only goes to 10 times the
player
level maybe this one's only 15 times the
player level
maybe this is
75 and then
burst we nerfed burst a little
bit are the Spells just too
good what do we
think spells are pretty
good q e
and
AE can it use both of these at level one
one after the
other I think it
we'll see whether this makes them more
balanced
let's see I think that they should maybe
tip it a little
bit the thing is I always think like you
want to make stuff better in games not
worse on the characters to feel
see okay let's see how far they pull
ahead
good assassin and tank falling behind is
not
good possibly the classes need Buffs
this is better
though they're not like running away
with the game as aggressively as
early especially if we're looking
compared to support they've got a two
level Advantage now it's starting to get
a little bit bad
Advantage so we will simply uh continue
a little bit Nerf we do a little
Nerf burst we already nerfed Health
damage gain per level is
Tiny they have pretty low HP gain for
level
already we'll buff the Assassin to be
100 HP gain per
is tank is doing the worst at the moment
tank needs the most
help I think the Mana gain is just
brutal on it
right let's increase the tank to 50
which is the minimum
yep that looks
better and so we
do so we changed
assassin yeah we didn't do anything with
the
carry or burst being ridiculous yet
though I mean what can I do
like they already have [ __ ]
burst is already
[Music]
car they're using the w a bunch let me
see
bad it's got to be something to do with
this slow right because
more wait hold
on this is supposed to be Q timer
oh well that's why they were spamming it
because they could spam it with no
freaking cool
down are they were were they spamming
wait let me
see no they weren't even using
it I guess cuz it triggers the cool down
for their other
[Music]
thing no cuz this is a attack skill
that's fine
we might have to rework a couple skills
here we'll
see it's a substantial enough Nerf
though
50 is there a block
diagram or is RL just not like that what
do you mean is there a block diagram
interestingly they do actually even out
later in the game meaning that the
scaling is weirdly nonlinear okay we
have to check the earlier game though
what do you mean though block diagram
I'm not not sure I know what that is in
this
context um yeah currently this
is this is game balancing using
reinforcement learning uh and the thing
that we're game balancing is an
environment for reinforcement learning
research it's like a mini version of
DOTA we're looking at all the skills the
agents use we're seeing which ones they
use we're seeing which different classes
are strong which ones are weak and we're
balancing pretty much in real time
because these things learn uh new metas
in like a few minutes they're pretty
all right let's see
so support is still up
there what did I do few more rounds of
balance let's uh let's open
up this this is not
good why is not
dealt
yeah kind
it's the same in the early
game and it's not all the same either
okay the support might be overed now
um but no the burst and carry are ahead
by a fair bit and they're going to pull
ahead
more
um I mean the tank kind of brawl right
it doesn't really kill anything
instantly but it does do pretty solid
damage over time assassin is supposed to
have low
damage assassin does burst damage that
just like kills stuff instantly it
doesn't do like long sustained
damage we should look more at hero kills
here what skill is
burst well the the difference like yes
there are very similar the Assassin has
more engage the Assassin literally has a
skill that teleports to the Target and
then does massive
damage the uh the burst class has like a
range uh range nuke skill but it doesn't
have as much followup because it can't
like AOE it can't like get close to like
Chase down with Autos what skill is it
it has like a blink
strike yeah uh okay yeah you're right so
it's not using it but it has it so if it
used it it would be pretty
good the Assassin is just not learning
to use its kit at the moment is all that
it comes down
to I might have to tweak some
stuff but yeah it's just not using its
kit
here yeah so these are some crazy
kills let's take a look at um I mean we
have all these nice plots right we may
as well look at
them um these should be organized for me
I don't know what
happened oh I do I need to sort these
into tabs like
I thought that I should have different
tabs for
these hold
on what's the thing isn't it like group
by
group yeah they normally
are something's weird with
this that's kind of
weird W is just being annoying today
let's see if we can see from here
anything okay so they do even out like
at the end game they even
out it's kind of
funny in level is not in hero kills at
all
I'm actually kind of surprised that the
tank doesn't do
better the tank has like a very healthy
skill pool it's just
not doing
damage well wait what about damage
received it should have a ton of damage
received
doesn't
though it's hard to say though because
it could just be getting one shot by the
other
two why are the burst and carry still so
dominant
okay we're going to do like a turbo Nerf
just to like
see okay so we're going to Turbo nuke
this to be like
20 so we're literally going to have the
scaling on the
burst all right
we're going to have the scaling on the
burst and then we are going
to uh we're going to put their
damage down to 15
we'll see if they're still good they
should not be they should be really bad
now I gotta say though being able to do
this Loop in like five minutes instead
of like two days is
they're still
good
huh
how literally
how okay I guess these agents are just
freaking seeing something I'm not
because this they should not
be I mean they should not be
good I mean I just like shredded their
classes they should not be able to do
this I I took away the car's damage
scaling Advantage so it's just a bad
squishy and I haveed the scaling on the
burst classes
spells admittedly it's much less
oppressive
now but it's still
outscaling somehow
okay now we got to sanity check this
because this makes no sense I'm glad I
did that
skills do you think that they'll be good
without
skills if so something's wrong
so took away their scaling Advantage
they should just be bad
classes
so they're not good right we have to let
it run for a little longer so so far
they look not
good and they should get
outscaled support using
W
um yeah
it'll I think it'll like if it just you
click the button it'll show you that or
something let me check
fine yeah cuz we only commented burst
and carry
skills and those are empty yeah we're
good
so they're not getting outperformed as
heavily as I would expect though
so they're falling behind behind but
they're actually barely falling
behind is the Assassin
using well the Assassin is pulling ahead
just by being able to get to fights
faster I
think so that makes sense it's not using
its kit
optimally and then
second oh actually the support is
q w and
E yeah it's using its skills the
support's Performing I'd say the the
support is actually performing as
expected and then it's the other ones
that are underperforming
so I think assassin has to get a
move maybe it gets like a move coold
down
Nerf a blink strike
buff I mean this thing's already
freaking
op we'll make it 100 Mana I think that's
like incredibly
generous and then what we'll do is
we'll we'll like make this move timer
much
longer so maybe then it learns that it's
got to like not just waste all its mana
on
this maybe that'll help we'll see and
then the tank tank
is tank is really underperforming I'm
actually very surprised by this cuz it
looks on paper it looks like it would be
the best it's using all its
skills what do we have for tank
scaling [ __ ] ton of HP gain per level
right 100 Mana per second for
this yeah maybe we just we'll give it
this a giga
buff and then self heal it's already
using it's on long cool down
though and then yeah this is a tech
skill so this is
I actually think we could increase
this this is not scaling heavily
enough I think it needs to be able to
heal like we want this to heal half your
health
maybe or 2third of your
health supposed to be a big skill so
700 divide by 2 is 350
but wait no 2/3
is let's do
400 still not
enough no but it is enough because yeah
it's
fine and 100
mana and we will slightly increase the
cool
down this should be a very strong tank
class
yeah then support's apparently in a good
spot somehow so
E it likes its stun
now cuz it stun does some
damage it's got to heal yeah it's a
pretty good
so this is again the same thing the same
sanity with like the gimped carry and
burst classes and we're just going to
see how the other ones do in
one of the cool things about DOTA is how
like everything's kind of
overpowered like all the the skills in
general are stronger I think than those
in
League I don't know games where like
everything feels overpowered are just
way better than games
where Everything feels
weak like you'd always rather have
everything just feel
broken as funny as that is
right we'll give this a couple of
minutes to
uh to
um is it still not using it
w I gave it like the most broken skill
ever and it's still not using it
anywhere near
there we
go so
it does seem like they're being enforced
somewhere
that it is starting to use its w a
little bit but not anywhere near
enough how's this looking
now okay support and assassin are doing
better
tank tank is up on damage but not on
levels
that what's the tank skill using it's
using its Q it's w and somewhat is e
that should be a very good channeled
20 I'm gon have to just start playing
these soon because I can't figure out
why these are not good
bit and man this is
weird I'm going to have to like start
playing
these let me take a moment what I'm
going to do now is it's
seven okay let's let me take a moment
to real quick let me go check the Atari
sweeps I'm going to launch a new Atari
sweep um
check we're going to make sure we're
using our Hardware overnight because
we're not going to get to run more Mobis
sweep it's going to take us one more day
of balancing I think though at least now
I have an understanding for this and I
know how to do it
sweep why does it not run longer
experiments than this
tell like some of these it looks like
they would keep going up
right it just stops running them
like this one could it not just run this
experiment for longer and have it do
better or does it like crash if you run
it for longer
okay so that works um
we already grabbed the best pams from
this so we're good
there let's see which one we want to do
next so we did a full run of
this I kind of want to do like beam
Rider
right let me see if I can find the beam
sweep I thought that one was really good
right here we
go
yeah so let's just do this thing with
the beam Rider to see if we just run it
for longer
test I'm just trying to load this
machine
now that'll run beam rider for three
days and if I continue doing this we'll
have all the nice Atari sweeps done
pretty
soon cool so in the meantime
here um
what am I going to do about
this I kind of want to just start
playing some of these
cool I think this
works and then what is
it
support number two is Assassin okay
let's try
this so my w and E are supposed to be
really good
it 250 Mana 500 health I'm definitely
the Assassin right
didn't do
[ __ ] okay what's going
oh well this is
weird am I not uh 5200 yeah I'm not the
Assassin
here I thought I handled that oh CU I'm
dumb this need to be
one
go let's see if this works
up so it's rendering me on the Assassin
but it's not showing the graphics and
it's not letting me control it
I want to be able to play this as
whatever
class tired to be debugging this though
like
then it is drawing around
it I think
so I'm assuming that there's just
somewhere where it's like still there's
a zero like there's a bad
index
oh I
you want to render from the first
environment this is selecting the
environment that you render
from let's see if this
works I'm going to order food
see can we blink strike onto
somebody yeah we can blink
strike it's pretty
sweet AE the
minions then then can we like blink
strike onto the
tower Bo I think we did I think we hit
it pretty
hard okay but we haven't rebuilt this in
a while
so we just should play the classes and
see how they play
so now this should be a single cost for
like activation of this for two seconds
doesn't feel as good maybe we'll revert
that and
then we still have our AOE which is a
q which should be very strong still
right okay our Q doesn't do what I
expected it to deserve blink strike
work let's
why I don't know if it's actually
respecting our cool Downs
that oh it's not respecting cool Downs
that's the
bug yeah that'll break
everything e
so what was basically happening is uh
things were broken as hell because there
were literally no cool
Downs that's kind of a fundamental
see now I'm spamming e and I can't
actually press it
anymore it's good so now I can do my
little AOE
nuke which could probably be
improved and
then you just do the AOE nuke again to
help the team out and then I blink
strike onto the tower which does quite a
bit of damage to
it and we take the
tower this class is pretty good as it
turns
out and should no longer be able to
spam I think with this fix alone I
should just retry some
stuff uh we're going to reenable the
classes
feed you ate yesterday tell them he ate
yesterday
look I am grumpy and I scowl when I hear
children laughing outside okay I'm
basically like 80-year-old grumpy German
man I hate fun as
pain yeah run a 50k is pretty
fun
last man pressing
what dueling bench
presses last man impressing winds yeah
that sounds
good why do every fiber supplement
contain 50%
lead yeah it turns out those are pretty
bad I'll tell you what I like
lately they're kind of fun because
they're also
sodas these are pretty
fun they're like maybe a seven out of 10
for a soda but it's a soda
if I could drink diet sodas normally or
even regular sodas I probably wouldn't
do this but all the artificial
sweeteners hurt my stomach and this has
Stevia which is the only one that
doesn't so it's pretty
good soda could be bad for you
how it's like it's literally
Stevia there's like nothing bad in it
for you
calories and teeth what's bad on your
teeth there's no sugar and there are no
calories I there like five or
something might be like
20 or the ones I have some of the
flavors are disgusting but I like their
Cola and their root
beer is pretty
good where's the freaking thing 35
calories whoopy Doo two grams of
water that's nothing why is there fiber
yeah that's what I was telling you it's
got probiotics prebiotics fiber
yeah it's pretty
good it's pretty
soda are these guys actually being
reasonable now let's
see holy hell look at that it turns out
when the Assassin is using its skills
it's really freaking good holy look at
that
okay no it's not fed it's just freaking
overpowered
kills he's not fed he's just strong
nobody's feeding him he's just he takes
what he wants he [ __ ] teleports on to
you and just one shots
you all right well that'll need to be
tuned support is in a good spot tank is
a little
I think we bring down there's no death
count at the moment should probably add
that
um I think what we're going to do is
we're going to bring assassin down just
a little bit and then we're going to
bring yeah there should be we're going
to bring assassin down just a little bit
and then we're going to bring everything
up to the level of assassin I think that
way it'll feel like it'll feel good to
play that way because assassin feels
very good to play right now
the skills feel
support something's wrong there I don't
know we'll look at
that might be the cool down we'll look
at
it make it global
that would be a crazy skill could you
think about if that existed in Dota
there's just a skill that just full
heals all of your entire team and your
minions and your
everything it doesn't heal your minions
and your Towers
right not Minion or Tower
healing it would be a really strong
pushing
buff all right let's uh let's take a
look I gotta order some food
first let me go do that on the other
monitor
real quick I order some
food I've gotten very sick of food
around here I don't know
how ordering the
food you're not cooking either are you
you have a wife doing that so shut up
let me see
exactly so shut up
order I would like a medium quantity of
food
I used to have a lot of spots that were
really good around here that just like
went out of business I still have some
places but it's a little harder
to get my stuff these days
man how do you know your breakout 300
and 300 is pito Frontier because the
image I posted is literally the Pito
Frontier that's been evaluated over 500
experiments
no that's Paro Frontier by
definition the set of all points where
given like two metrics or if you're
given multiple metrics there exist no
points that are strictly better meaning
better in both metrics that's the
definition of poo optimality and in this
case the two metrics are score and
compute
time no it's just the ones on the Edge
that are the best it's the frontier Pito
Frontier yeah those are all the best in
the sense that like every single point
there there is not another point on that
uh there is not another experiment that
is both faster and higher
score that's how that works poo
optimality is one of the few Concepts
from convex opt and like higher math
that's ridiculously
useful like PR optimality is
ridiculously useful
think I've been ordering from like this
kind of mid Italian place lately that's
just like I swear a total heer
restaurant can't do that too often you
turn into a
econ no not econ convex opt my
friend
heer that's not how you spell is that's
not I don't think that's how you spell
heer is it
good I order from this place I should
find more I should find better Asian
restaurants in the area I'm sure there
are lots of them
every so often I want the ever so
slightly Americanized
version I never want like kungpow
chicken or anything but sometimes I want
this so slightly Americanized
version what did you change with M hold
on I fixed big
bug uh what I fixed this
time uh the cool Downs were just not not
happening so it was just able to spam
stuff it turns out that uh the agents
are smart and I am dumb so it was just
spamming the mobility because it was
able to do it off cool like there was no
cool down so it was just using all its
mana on mobility and didn't save
anything for anything else
where let's see the
tank
24K yeah so this is all selfhealing the
tank can only heal itself so itself
healed a bunch and got a little bit from
the support the support didn't heal
anywhere near enough so that needs to be
buffed but the tank did exactly what
it's supposed to be able to do and it
tanked a bunch of damage so this is
actually perfect now um it's a little
underst sted or something it's
low-leveled but yeah this is
good that's exactly what we want on the
tank though like look at this damage
received you see it's healed itself all
of this and it's tanked the extra damage
for the
team yeah support needs to uh not be
killing
44 though to be fair maybe it's okay for
it to kill 44 maybe it's just that the
tank needs to kill you know
right how did we do on the X
game
4420 solid
44 seems extreme not really supports
aren't just supposed to sit there right
supports are supposed to do
things they're supposed to fight and do
stuff right they're not just supposed to
be dead weight
yeah a good way to keep the carry alive
is by killing the other
support
right supports can be
aggressive it's not all like be the
magic cat and [ __ ] like Press buttons
and don't touch your mouse
popular in bot
Lane I don't think anybody's everever
popular in that game but the funny thing
with the mobas is like coming from MMOs
it's just the nicest and most welcoming
Community imaginable cuz
like I mean you know if you've played
MMOs the MMOs chat rooms are legendary
all right so now we can actually balance
this thing
properly it uses its Q its Q is pretty
balanced I like
it tend to have welcoming
communities brother have you seen
RuneScape I swear RuneScape gen chat is
like it's worse than
4chan it's actually like worse than
forchan yeah we're going to we're going
to fix all
that assassin TP damage all right this
is freaking broken so we're going to
Nerf
this we're going to Nerf it a little
bit not crazy
I think it can do 300 at base level
including the
buff we're going to Nerf it by 100
damage all right 100 damage is
all how much Mana does the Assassin
I think we're going to give this
thing you're going to get actually five
seconds of move time so it's going to
actually get a buff but it's going to
get a Nerf to the time a 20 second cool
down on this very long cool
down and
then they maybe don't have much
moderation yeah exactly screw
moderation yes a long cool
down yeah it's a really strong ability
it gives you double speed for five
seconds hey Elon
hey my ideal chat experience is that I
get to set my own filters
right I don't need somebody setting them
for for
me he walked it back a little bit and
frankly I wish he
occasionally again you need good filters
as
well
but it's Health base Mana I think the
abilities can cost a little more is the
one thing
like this is fine at 100 I think that we
can
to you shouldn't be able to use all
three
skills so I think this will be
people have good stuff to say don't need
to say it under an
exceptional
Banner can't use I mean you can't like
just press all your buttons at if you
have them 100 each at level one you can
just press all your
buttons
right you can do that later anyways but
it's a little much at level one you can
literally just press all your buttons at
once
actually we're GNA make this 125 as
well does it use
it no it already doesn't use this one a
ton I think we'll leave this one as is
we'll set this one to
and then let's see the other ones so
support support is probably in a good
spot it might need a small damage
Nerf what skills does it use it uses it
q a little it's w a ton and it's e not a
ton this is actually fine I don't know
why the healing is not good enough
somehow
still damage Nerf and healing buff it's
already using its healing way more than
it's using this support stun
skill which does
damage I can Nerf it by 50
points we're not messing with the
rewards right
now oh this is why it's the scaling the
scaling is dog [ __ ] that's
why
um yeah this is just this is bad so this
needs to be
250 and then 75 times the player level I
think that's maybe wait that might be
too
much that's probably too much right
that's like a full heal for some of them
HP per
level yeah it should be 50 not 75 I
think yeah negative damage is healing in
this it's weird it's
fine okay so the AOE I think it's fine
other than this we're probably
good and support
now let's look at tank tank needs some
help I think tank is falling behind in
levels its damage is
in its damage is very good actually how
is its
kills actually it might be
good it's using all of its
skills it's just falling behind and
level just a little bit it's really not
even that much though is it no it's
level with the support I think we just
leave it as
is
yeah I think tank is happy there for
now 60 cool down yeah it's five ticks
per second so that's uh 12 seconds
so every 12 seconds it can do this which
is like a pretty decent I think that's a
good cool
down so then I guess we just look at the
two that used to be op which are the
burst and the carry and they
have 80 and
70 these are the crazy nerfed versions
though aren't they
yeah these are the nerfed versions of
these so I don't know how these are any
good so we probably should look at
this like how in particular how's the
carry any
e which are also very
bad it has this AOE but it doesn't scale
that
well okay I actually don't know the
carry is
good like how is this good I should just
play it
right yeah I should probably just play
it that's index
4 what do you mean is it's not good look
at his
stats Heroes killed SL carry
70 no it has it has 70 kills right
here and support has
40 what do you want
about
yeah it's kind of op
I mean how is this any good like I have
crap
stats so many kills but not much
level they're it all they're all like
endgame
I don't think I recompiled this since I
fixed the
bug red puffer creeps are heroes the
light red ones are creeps the dark red
ones are
I cannot tell the difference well if
you'd like to go and make us a full set
of assets for this game you can do that
but you're probably not going to be a
fun
died cuz my only AO I think I have like
this light AOE with my e but that's all
I
have didn't even get any
XP yeah I was mashing the
buttons I think I have to mash e more
maybe
I don't see how this is supposed to be
good
what's wrong with the neutrals here I
think I'm just not spawning neutrals for
some reason
I think I am chunking the tower
here because I I do have decent damage
scaling but no more than the
says Carry has level
24 has 70 kills and it has
has damage dealt is
food W and E this is the last thing I'm
going to look at I think for today
this is really bad scaling
though
instant some are channeled so they like
keep going but the activation
instant this is really weird to me that
this is any
good I don't think I can Nerf this until
I understand why this is a
problem you can use any ability that has
sufficient Mana cast that is not on cool
down and we can see exactly that they're
using these two
abilities the
slow the
AOE they're actually using the slow more
often which does like ply little
damage these abilities just shouldn't be
strong though so what I don't understand
right is like I nerfed this thing so
heavily already that look they only get
15 damage per level which is the same as
the tank
if I look the tank actually has very
similar damage dealt but it has way
fewer
kills it could just be from the uh the
AOE or
whatever but the thing is like I want to
buff the carry a bunch I don't see
how it doesn't really
need the AOE either
and then the burst has the burst is
currently doing very well but I also
nerfed it
scaling well I think maybe we just need
to rerun this because the Assassin kind
of went
with any added skill comes another pass
it game balancing no well I can do a
bunch at the same time cuz like the
reinforcement learned agents will just
decide on their own whether they think
it's good or not that's kind of cool I
don't have to wait for player feedback
it's like the RL agents just do it
so yeah we'll run this for a few minutes
if uh let me
see yeah food's not here yet so we'll
we'll just do this for a few
minutes and then I'll run an Atari
experiment
overnight I guess there's not going to
really be much point in doing that huh
well we'll
see because I'm not going to be able to
run the full sweep because I'm going to
need this box back
tomorrow all right well I could run uh I
could run something slightly different
in the
meantime better check puffer Li PRS
is there anything urgent here
fine yeah it's just an extra setting
whatever you can have
with do we not need this oh you put it
down here
you're supposed to be able to pass this
explicitly
fine is this in clean RL it should
be um
RL
yeah is this
um what is this
I'm a little confused as to what this is
hold on this is the one I'm concerned
with I assume this is squared or what
like spaces
whatever so correctly fix
it oh stochastic
where the hell was
it oh
do you know what short circuiting is in
in
conditionals if not I'll teach you one
thing it's very basic and like you'd get
it from any first course in CS but
this
mhm but I have here 1 /
0 but you see in the conditional here I
have something that will produce an
error
so this runs because it checks that this
one is valid and since this is an or it
doesn't have to evaluate the second
condition it does not execute the one
over zero if it executed the one over
zero it would fail so if I do like this
see this is a feature of every basically
every programming
language so what I would have done in
your case right is like
you know
thing if tick zero
or pression
else right I would have done that but
it's
fine now you know
that and this does not count as a fancy
trick either this is like this is a
feature of basically every
single this is a feature of like every
programming language ever you're taught
this in your first course in computer
science and uh you use it for this
purpose so you're 100% allowed to do
that it's pretty
fun very basic but cool thing I could
teach you
today holy hell I made the assassin even
stronger
somehow well that's going to take some
balance make a new PR I'll merge it
whenever
that I don't think that
ever I don't know what the OS Makers
Thing returns I don't know if it returns
true if it works because if so that
never
executes yeah that's a whoops yeah oh no
none yeah then you shouldn't do
that then you shouldn't do that you
shouldn't just have a something that
always evaluates to fall you put it in a
different
line no I know that it works but there's
no reason to do that like you just put
the thing in a different line that's
like golfing
it yeah I know why that works but
like don't do that don't [ __ ] do that
man okay but
like that's literally the same thing if
is like on lining
like you can do that
too right
oh I wonder if you can still do
this oh yeah you can still do this
[Laughter]
do you dep all your bars in one
line not usually
no generally it's preferred to do one
line per variable def but if I just have
like a bunch of indices sometimes I'll
on line
them yeah I don't think you can do
this yeah you can't do that
but you can override
functions so now we don't have a print
function oh look that's the second one
today thanks
twitch
goodbye see
you dumb
bot all right my food's here I got to go
um let me load something real quick onto
this just to load something onto the box
for
now I did want to try
something because I was a little
confused about one thing
yeah I actually there we need to make
separate configs CU there's one that
you're specifically not supposed to be
allowed to use an RNN on CU it breaks
the test U and then there are other ones
where you specifically need to have an
RNN or it won't
work they're tests like they're intended
they're intentionally constructed that
way all right I'm going to go get food
it's uh 8:00 p.m. so it's been cool
we'll be doing more work tomorrow MOA is
making good progress and I'll see you
around thanks for hanging around bet by